so it's getting crazy over the
netherlands these uh farmers are
protesting because the government's
putting restrictions on farming
in a video going viral in a story that's
going viral police officers opened fire
on one of the farmers as they were
protesting
and uh you combined this story i mean
boris johnson resigning is is partly
involved with the the the georgia
guidestones being knocked over you look
at what's going on around you and it
feels like the
liberal economic order or the liberal
world order as these establishment
uniparty elites like to call it it's
collapsing they're failing
i'll tell you one thing right away so
you can understand the the netherlands
story with the farmers we're being told
two things at once
that ukraine is the bread basket of
europe and they can't produce food
because of the war because of the war
with russia and we're not getting
fertilizer because of the war with
russia so there's going to be a global
famine coming
at the same time they're going to
farmers in the netherlands saying stop
producing food now how does that make
sense something does not add up so this
story is actually fairly big we'll talk
about that too we also have bill gates
in the news rather consistently over the
past several weeks because he's buying
up a ton of farmland hmm i have to
wonder about that and then we have uh oh
man i hate to say it but a video of
hunter biden apparently smoking crack
has has been published
and he's doing other things that i can't
say because they're not family friendly
and he filmed himself doing it and all
of this is reflecting on on his dad
who's giving him money to fund a lot of
this stuff that's what we're learning
now and for some reason these never
trumpers are acting like ron desantis is
the bigger threat
it's uh uh it's really interesting isn't
it so we'll talk about all that plus
we're going to talk a lot about what's
going on the southern border
texas is going to be taking a lot of
illegal immigrants sending them back to
the border and in arizona
well in arizona they want the governor
to declare an invasion is occurring and
we have a great guest to talk to us
about all of that but before we get
started head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com
this show is brought to you by virtual
shield the virtual private network
service you can get 50 off lifetime
discount at surfing internetsafe.com a
virtual private network from virtual
shield is a basic layer of security for
you as you browse the web so if you're
con if you're concerned about
governments hackers corporations
stealing your data
get virtual shield
and they say
their vpn service is compatible with all
devices it allows you to browse the web
safely and securely and anonymously
using their global network of private
servers and ips when using their vpn
service your traffic is routed through
encrypted service servers meaning all
restrictions censorship and blocks on
your internet are bypassed it's
completely free for 30 days available on
mac windows iphone ipad android chrome
virtual shield does all the work for you
you download it you open up you press go
it's that simple
they route your internet through their
advanced encrypted servers across the
globe to prevent isps and others from
tracking you which we mentioned they've
got personal family and business plans
available the family plan includes 15
devices and the business plan allows you
to add as many employees as you need and
virtual shield will completely encrypt
your wi-fi connection as well blocking
hackers and everyone else from accessing
any of your data
virtual shield is the first first
sponsor that uh i ever had on youtube so
we're really grateful that they've stuck
with us through everything that's
happened with all the craziness and the
censorship
don't give money to people who hate you
give give your money to corporations to
companies that actually care about you
that are willing to get behind shows
like this so go to surfing internet safe
but speaking of giving your money to
people who don't hate you go to
timcast.com become a member in the top
right click sign up
if it look if you want to give money to
the big massive streaming services by
all means you you're free to do what you
want but allow me to say we are trying
as hard as possible and we are building
this company we're working every single
day to compete with and rival these
companies we're a long ways off but with
your support at timcast.com we're adding
new shows
we're adding uh new talk shows new
investigative journalists all the time
we've added a couple journalists
recently with your support we will grow
this company and we're gonna have a
members only show for you at 11 pm
tonight you don't want to miss it so
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends without further ado
joining us to talk about everything
happening in the news as well as arizona
is gubernatorial candidate carrie lake
it's good to be back thanks for having
me tim do you want to introduce yourself
yeah i am an arizonan i've lived in
arizona since 1994. i i drove out there
as a a young 20-something
journalist to cover the great state of
arizona i covered it for 27 years
and then during covid as a number one
news anchor and journalist in the state
i decided that i was going to walk away
from my career because i no longer felt
that i could tell the full truth and and
when i did that an amazing thing
happened the people of arizona reached
out i put a video out of course and said
hey i'm leaving this is why and they
reached out and said would you please
consider running for office we need
somebody we can trust that's amazing so
i was kind of recruited to run for
governor and and we threw our hat in the
ring last june a year ago june and we've
been number one in the polls since then
and now we are officially in election
month because we don't have election day
in arizona so we're in the primary
election right now and we're doing quite
well in the polls we've been ahead the
entire time and we are pushing to bring
an america first candidate trump
endorsed candidate into the governor's
office in arizona to turn things around
and secure our border i like the gun
stuff
and the gun stuff fighting for gun
rights fighting for well we're already a
great gun state i mean if you want your
second amendment rights intact come to
arizona we're even ahead of texas
we're always at risk of losing them when
we have maniacs in the white house who
are trying to take them away i'm looking
forward to talking about how the media
has been smearing you too because a lot
of people get smeared by the media but
don't have decades of media experience
so it'll be interesting to see you know
to talk to you about that so we'll get
in all that stuff thank you for joining
us thanks for being here for having me
yes thank you for being here
we also have mary morgan happy to be
back you're putting up with me tim yeah
i'm mary i'm the co-host of pop culture
crisis on youtube we cover more
light-hearted stuff on there things
about celebrities movies tv shows
all the drama and when you super chat
you can shoot money at us so go check it
out there's there's money guns that when
the super chats come in it sprays money
into the air yeah all right hi everyone
ian crossland in the house good to see
you carrie i'm glad you're back i
haven't seen you for like a year almost
yeah a little at least you haven't been
following our campaign i have been i saw
a video of you talking to i think it was
a cnn reporter trying to get an
interview oh yeah yeah that was great so
funny i mean you were just so direct and
like
like yeah i'll talk to you sure put it
on cnn plus and then we'll talk that was
fantastic it's nice to see you in your
element yes that was fun great to see
you again and the shirt that i have a
carrie lake shirt it's the best uh
material like most comfortable material
all my shirts i call it day to night
shirt you can wear it all day and then
you can sleep in it yeah if you don't
want to like you know put your pajamas
on super soft are you selling those we
do sell those and um
yeah but i think we can get you one we
can get you a deal on one let's talk
what color do you need i like the purple
one well i have one
i'm so delighted that you're back i'm
excited to hear what's going on in your
campaign i saw a few of your ads and
your video with that cnn reporter are
definitely what put you back on my radar
so yeah
it's good to see you again lydia well
let's uh before we get into all the
domestic stuff let's talk about what's
going on with this this global agenda we
have this story this is a really freaky
story from timcast.com dutch government
shoots live rounds at farmers protesting
mandates lawmakers enacted restrictive
laws to combat climate change dutch
police opened fire using live ammunition
against farmers protesting the
government's mandatory restrictions and
closure of some farms to meet climate
goals set by the european union this is
really fascinating we've got tons of
tweets here i'll break this uh breaking
this down shots fired police said the
tractor drivers attempted to drive into
officers and service vehicles i got to
say if you watch the video that's not
true
it's a tractor that just drives around
like it pulls out it's going going down
the road and then a cop just fires at
him the tractors don't go that fast
right it's like it's like austin powers
yeah you know you guys remember that
scene with the steam roller yeah yeah
the steam roll the guy's like no are you
kidding
here's here's what's really really crazy
about this so in the context of the
georgia guidestones being blown up we um
i can't say too much because we have
some journalists investigating this
but uh let's let me just say that there
are some sources involved who say it
appears to be a politically motivated
attack obviously someone went and blew
up the georgia guide stones what they
call the monument to globalism but let
me make this point
we have a fertilizer shortage because of
the war with russia and ukraine
we have russia and ukraine reducing
their exports of food to neighboring
nations which is supposed to cause a
global famine
and at the same time as we're being
warned about all this at the same time
we're hearing you know germany other
countries panicking over a lack of fuel
european nations are telling their
farmers to stop farming here's the
crazier thing we're being told we're
going to get hit by rising food costs
a lower crop yield and potential food
shortages in the united states and we're
even hearing from people in the industry
they're chatting us saying farmers in
the us are still being paid not to farm
so what is going on and you forgot to
mention all the food processing plants
that are burning down that the news
isn't covering well so so i mean they're
covering it it's just not in the
mainstream national cycle now i i will
say to that point
we've we've
questioned whether or not it's abnormal
the amount of fires
and so we got uh these fact takers came
after us and they were like tim cass
published fake news claiming that all
these fires were happening
and our article was bad don't get me
wrong like we had some errors that's
true but
we did some digging and it looks like
it's slightly above average the amount
of that's normal i saw the list that
went on and on and on i'm like wow and
this i really haven't seen much on it so
there's there's you know what tens of
thousands of warehouses tens of
thousands of factories fires happen
you what we got to be careful of is
sometimes like a car crash happens near
a building and then people are like oh
what was this but what i can say is even
on that story it does look like there
are more there's more fires than there
there have been over the past few years
by a small amount so
take it for what it is either way i'll
say this these fires are a new story
because we're being told there's going
to be a food shortage more importantly
if these fires are happening and they
are normal isn't that grounds to tell
farmers to pick up production get up
yeah start producing we have we have the
same thing because of water issues in
arizona there's a lot of fields that are
fallow that you're just not putting any
you know you're not planting
and there's obviously a concern you know
we talk about water issues in arizona
but i say if we keep
handling water issues with more
restrictions restrictions we hurt the
farming and then we have a food shortage
and it sounds like
they're setting us up for a food
shortage amazing why would you tell
farmers not to farm is it because they
don't have transport to get the farm the
food out and they don't want rotten food
but but that's incumbent upon the
farmers to figure out not the government
to come in and prevent
right you know farmers are so busy that
they don't mess around i'm from iowa
which is an agriculture state originally
and if you've got farmers protesting and
spending days and nights doing this
you've really pissed off the wrong
people well so so
we can talk about fallowing fields and
all that stuff and government
paying farmers not to farm but in the
netherlands why are they this is about
climate change they're telling these
farmers to reduce emissions and things
like that because of climate goals
do they not suspend these things when
they're like hey a global famine is
coming and europe is going to starve
because ukraine's being invaded by
russia this makes literally no sense and
then to see the police open fire on them
it just reeks of
the global agenda is collapsing it's a
climate change agenda that's what
they're doing joe biden has said he was
campaigning we're going to get off
fossil fuels now what happens he's
shutting down oil and gas leases he's
banning fracking and other oil leases on
public lands and uh we just found out
joe biden
allowed five million barrels of our
strategic reserves to be exported this
country to china of all places not just
but europe and asia as well
something doesn't make sense with what
they're doing and you look at you look
at all this stuff and it really does
feel like like just joe biden's crooked
as they come
oh i mean
that's a fact
we've known about this for a while you
look at the laptop you see everything
that's on that laptop and you see
evidence of
dealings with our enemies
financial dealings that should have been
told by the way before the election but
you know that we'll save that for
another day
um he never puts america first
no it's more like biden family first
biden family first his friends in china
first his friends in ukraine you know 58
billion dollars of our taxpayer money
has gone to ukraine
and we have a crisis at the border i
mean we've got families who are
struggling they can't make ends meet
they can't afford the groceries they
can't afford to put gas in their car
and we're sending our hard-earned money
to ukraine
this is insane and then and then you add
on top of it the left
pushing these environmental um mandates
on us to the point of trying to i don't
know i don't know what the point is
actually are we trying to save other
animals by hurting the human race
i i i kind of feel like
you know you see these posts from
democrats when the ukraine war kicked
off and they were saying things like
five you know four dollars a gallon is
the price to pay to see ukraine be free
and things like that you had joe biden
say gas prices will remain high as long
as it takes for ukraine to win
i encourage all of the democrats to run
that slogan in november and in 2024 so
when the voter walks up to the gas pump
and they're picking up the gas pump and
looking at the five bucks a gallon and
then those little tv plus little tvs
play and it'll be like breaking news joe
biden says you got to pay for ukraine
keep saying it keep saying and see if
you win and didn't one of his uh his
advisors say this the gas prices are
going to remain high until we get the
liberal world order oh yeah he said it's
what did he say
sure yeah
liberal
and it was basically like we're going to
suffer in america because we need to
prop up the liberal world order which is
the decimation of america which is the
decimation of the middle class the
working class they've been working at
this for a generation now and it started
back in the i think it started back in
the 80s when they started closing up the
manufacturing and the political elite
sold out our companies to
china it was in 1946 is when it began
they started the liberal economic order
1946 to prevent world war iii they were
like we need to set up a world police
and eisenhower warned us about it he's
like yo this military industrial complex
he called it but they started out they
used american military as the as the tip
of the spear and then now they're using
the american
economy with the federal reserve they're
making it print a bunch of money to prop
up all this militant activity to prevent
world war iii it did work for the time
but i don't think we need it anymore
personally although maybe we do because
we have things like bricks which is like
uh china russia india that have their
own kind of economic order well bricks
just is the it's an acronym for the
countries brazil russia india china
south africa yep that's really easy to
run and it's like one or the other i
don't know if we if there isn't some
sort of global militant stand standard
there's something there sometimes you
think that biden is more loyal to bricks
than us well so we we actually i haven't
heard from newsweek it was by an advisor
brian d saying this is about the future
of the liberal world order and we have
to stand firm here's what's amazing
10 years ago
if you were to bring up something like
that you were a crackpot if you said
here is this isn't it so amazing if you
came out and said there are global
elites
orchestrating what's happening around
the world
for for their special interest they
called you a crackpot now they come out
on tv and say it they just go on cnn and
say this is what we're doing here's the
best part
there was a poll i saw and it said
something like 53 of republicans believe
that the world is being run by a a ring
of
a global elite international what you
say child abusers okay and it was framed
as though these people were crackpot
crazy conspiracy theorists like
pizzagate stuff and it's like you look
at that story and then a week later
they're like elaine maxwell sentenced to
20 years for the elite global
trafficking among world leaders and we
don't know where client list is
now look you want to argue that that is
the the um intent behind what they do
internationally i don't know what we do
know is epstein maxwell well that
happened now we'd like to know who they
were dealing with we know that a bunch
of people global elites were flying on
those planes but my point ultimately is
this it was a conspiracy theory 15 years
ago now we actually just read the news
about maxwell getting convicted getting
sentenced to 20 years now it's all just
happening and we see the guy saying uh
liberal world order isn't that crazy i
suppose they want us to think that
they're not smart or organized enough to
do any of this with malicious intent and
i think that's what biden hides behind
is that everyone views him as the senile
old man
but that's the joke
well we made the joke that you know
biden goes up on stage and he's like uh
we gotta come on you know
better calf care and then everyone
laughs then he walks off stage bro and
then as soon as he's behind the scenes
he goes all right where was i i want you
to bomb those kids we're invading let's
go send 60 billion to ukraine ukraine
it's kind of sick if he is like okay
with being the laughing stock
it's really sick to think that his son
biden or his son hunter has been like
the i guess the brains behind a lot of
these financial
uh illegal financial
dealings that that
vice well president biden has been
behind i i think he's the proxy i think
hunter biden is the tool that joe uses
to skirt the law
why so look he flew to china on air
force two he brings hunter along with
him hunter biden does these private
equity deals with china
i think that's all joe
so joe makes the arrangement and then
hunter kind of signs on the dotted line
i mean think about it there's there's
laws
um i mean look at look at how any rich
person tries to evade taxes or give
money to families like you can't do it
right
we got reports that joe and hunter were
sharing bank accounts so here's the here
i'll give you the simple hypothetical
joe biden goes to uh ian as vice
president and says i'm going to build
some buildings in your country it's
going to be great that your economy is
going to boom
my son needs a favor though totally
unrelated
then the country does a deal or special
interest do deals with his son and he
goes don't look at me what my son does
his own business i don't even ask him
about it i don't talk to him about it
remember he said that then we got a
photograph of him with hunter and his
business associates and now we have a
voicemail of joe saying i read the piece
it looks like you're in the clear he
actually said that yeah i think joe is
doing the deals and he's using his son's
name to collect the money that's why in
that email they were like ten percent
for the big guy these people are correct
yeah all i know is it's a messed up
family i don't want to i don't want to
go too deep into the election but i
don't feel he should be in the white
house
and well he's run this country into the
ground he's run the country into the
ground and that's one of the reasons i'm
fighting so hard in arizona because
we're not going to let him take arizona
down with him
and it's going to come to the states
each state to say no back off we'll
we're going to go back to states rights
here and protect our own people i dig it
let's get a little bit more into the
domestic issues and uh i want to say i'm
just i'm sorry it's coming to this for
people who are watching you might not
want your kids to hear this stuff this
stuff's dark stuff
but this is the president's son
the daily mail reports
naked hunter biden filmed himself
smoking crack drinking hard seltzer
and um
you can do itself you can just say that
you can you can read it yourself at home
yeah while floating inside a sensory
deprivation tank one month after
convincing dad joe to wire him twenty
thousand dollars for his detox program
the first family the son of the
president
these videos are coming out because the
laptop got released and the stuff we're
learning about this family is is dark
it's bad stuff
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
and my in my personal opinion i think
joe biden was abusive towards his kids
because you don't turn out like hunter
biden unless you had bad parents doing
something
bad family
you you take a look at how hunter biden
turned out
and then you have to ask yourself about
the leadership capabilities of joe biden
and then you look at the country and you
start to put it together right
so i don't i don't know uh you know what
you guys what your thoughts are on all
this stuff more more of this is going to
keep coming out i think it absolutely is
indicative of who the democrats are
willing to elect regardless of their
moral character and of the leadership
capabilities of the man himself that is
the point right there we knew we knew
there were problems this is not news to
a lot of people i was following this
before the 2020 election i knew a lot of
this before the 2020 election and the
fact that the media kept that the
corporate media bosses kept that from
making its way to the people so they
could make an educated vote and decision
when they when they went to vote uh
twitter
but there were a lot of democrats who
probably knew that and said they didn't
like trump so they so wanted to get
president trump out that they were
willing to vote for someone like that
here's you know the reality is
trump has done bad stuff you know he
he's he's said mean things he called
stormy dale's horse face he called
didn't he call someone a fat pig or
something like that rosie o'donnell
rosie o'donnell only rosie o'donnell i
don't remember that from the debate only
rosie o'donnell but here's here's the
issue the overall majority of the bad
things they claimed trump did they made
up
they they they fabricated it
so with
i just don't want to i don't want to get
distracted by donald trump when we're
talking about the biden family yeah it
has its own thing that's pretty horrific
when you when you start to dig it open
agreed agreed my point is just we had to
win an election in 2020 and it was
between trump it was between biden and
what the biden voters are going to say
is you expected me to vote for trump he
called white supremacists very fine
people which he never was really did
exactly and so they believe the lies
about trump they believe the lies about
people like kyle rittenhouse i tweeted
the kyle rittenhouse thing was put me up
put me over the edge to vote for trump
because i saw how they're trying to
destroy this guy and we needed to push
back and stop this
and that was you and trump pinned it to
his profile on twitter and that was used
by many on the left to accuse me of
being wrong or being right-wing or
whatever or far right
but i was correct when in fact you
actually had the courage to stand up and
say the truth about a young man who was
being persecuted
and and they wanted to tear you apart
and destroy you and when that happened
to you you probably went oh i think i
know a little bit what it must be like
to be president trump right now i'm
feeling that myself because i'm already
attacked right now
and you're getting 150th of it uh
exactly i talked to president trump
regularly and i said i know i'm getting
the trump treatment right now and you
know he
you said he's done some bad things i
don't think he has i disagree with you
on that i think he's done some amazing
things his family i know them they're
incredible people
but the media has been tearing them
apart relentlessly
since 2015 2016
and some people have just bought into
that because they still believe the
media and what i want to tell people
after working in it for 30 years is turn
it off do not believe it they've got an
agenda and you just can't believe it i
mean honestly i'm getting better
information here at tim cast you're
putting out i'm listening to you before
this show and you're very thoughtful on
what you're putting out and making sure
things are accurate we're not all
perfect sometimes you make a mistake
i'm watching you and after working 30
years in tv and in journalism i'm
thinking this is more journalism than
what i was seeing in journalism the last
at least five six years i will say to
clarify my point on trump i think trump
is great i think uh
i can understand why people don't like
his character i've i tell these stories
i've talked to regular people so they
don't like the way he talks but i know a
lot of people do like the way he talks
and the way i saw it was we needed
someone to fight back especially with
the media lying by people like kyle
rittenhouse but uh no no one's perfect
we needed a
brash
new yorker to come in remember he beat
back 18 other
republicans many of them rhinos
establishment swamp creatures we needed
a tough brash new yorker who told it
like it was we couldn't get some
mealy mouth person to do that and thank
god he came in at that point but there
are things that trump uh
here's what i want to say
what joe biden is
i view him as corrupt
i view trump as having done bad things
as either mistakes or making bad
decisions people are allowed to make
mistakes people are allowed to make bad
decisions you criticize them for it and
say do better there's things about
donald trump that i personally don't
like but for the most part i think he's
a good guy i think he was actually a
really great president
um i don't like some of his foreign
policy decisions but i overwhelmingly
like his foreign policy
so commando raid
potentially killed a little girl an
american citizen that's what we've heard
i would like to see an inquiry into that
getting our troops out of the middle
east was the first president in my
lifetime who not only did not start a
war but was actually ending wars so for
that
here's what here's what i want to be
careful of if you come out you're just
like trump is the best he's so good then
people are people who have questions
about things he's done they they shut
they closed down
but i also don't want to play this game
where it's like oh trump was so awful
when the reality is oh yeah it wasn't
perfect he did some things that i think
were questionable wrong or just bad but
joe biden is uh
yeah 100. i think yeah what you're
saying is you're trying to say hey you
know trump wasn't perfect we're all
humans but joe biden is not just
imperfect he is corrupt malicious he's
malicious and you look at his family we
know trump's got attacked and his
children got attacked joe biden raised
this family and if you look at his
daughter's diary i mean
this is crossing the line in a serious
way where police should have been
involved possibly even arrests involved
joe biden there's such insidious
stuff in that family yeah and it's not
just the reasons that people dislike
either of them but they're such an
organic
appeal to trump whereas the support for
biden is all
reluctant support
because they hated trump i don't see
anybody
enthusiastic about biden never and i
didn't see it before 2020. so brazenly
just screwing the american people it's
almost like their hatred for president
trump is so
overwhelming and eating them up that
they're willing to sacrifice our country
our constitution our freedoms
okay we got them out i don't know if
it's actually that they hate trump i
don't know if they're smart enough to
actually hate the man
so i think it may have been austin
peterson lydia heard me if i'm wrong who
was talking about a friend of theirs
but we had a guest on saying uh their
friend believed they were like a liberal
democrat that trump called white
nationalists very fine people
and so he said just here read the
transcript and the person started
reading it and then like paused and then
scrolled back and started reading it
again and then just froze got up and
left the room unable to process the fact
that that donald trump never said white
nationals were very fine people i don't
remember who that was that was awesome
peterson it was also peterson yeah i
remember that and it was a huge story
and i remember hearing his entire
remarks and going i don't remember him
saying that then the media would
perpetuate it over and over and i even
went back
a couple of times and listened to what
president trump said to am i hearing
something wrong because everyone's
saying
he said this and i remember hearing that
looking back at it a couple times just
to make sure i didn't mishear it so
don't i don't think they hate trump i
mean they do hate him but what i mean to
say is
it's not real because they don't know
they didn't investigate they didn't
bother to i think what actually
motivates these people is fitting in
so you walk around new york and everyone
just says oh yeah i hate trump too and
so they go okay that's their identity
fitting in social is more important
right than than
being uh inquisitive and finding out the
truth for me i do you think people
living in more conservative areas do the
same thing
i've
because i live in a red state
i think we're a little bit we're a lot
more um who cares what they think about
us we want the truth
now not to say we don't have people in
in arizona who are like you just
described they're more
the peer pressure gets to them that's
why when i see to be honest a young
conservative and we have a lot of them
involved in our campaign
and they'll say oh my gosh i'm so
inspired by you and i think oh i'm a
middle-aged woman of course i'm going to
be bossy and and tell it like it is this
is what middle-aged women do right
but i say no i'm i'm inspired by you
when there's a young person 18 20 years
old 22 who's pushing back against that
peer pressure is that what you still
call it peer pressure is that an
outdated word they're pushing back
against their social pressure social
media
and speaking the truth um
that is actually very courageous well
let's let's talk about the founding
fathers because before the show we had
some interesting uh data points lydia do
you saw that data about the founding
fathers yeah do you want to read it sure
well we pulled it up and it looks like
the founding fathers were i want to say
james monroe was 18 years old 18. this
is these are the signers
18 years old yep two of them were 20
years old the oldest one mentioned here
was no thomas jefferson was 33. wow we
have 20 20 and 25. who were the 20
madison was 25 i believe so i saw that
the responses to that
it's a tweet right listen
to the story i saw a tweet that was
listing those ages and their responses
were like well it's because the life
expectancy back then was like 45 so an
18 year old was the same as a 35 year
old that's not true
yeah the reason the average life
expectancy was so low was because of
infant mortality but if you survived
infancy you were expected to live
together 70 or 80 years old yeah we were
talking i think it was ian and i were
saying and i would take a 9 or ten year
old from that era because they were so
competent they could
farm they could hunt they could do
anything they were so
resourceful i would trade them probably
for you know the average person in
america today who is not able to to have
those survival skills that they had
somebody's stoned on aspartame
crazy fake children we're not we're not
practically skilled or
emotionally
sophisticated like developed either well
you talked about what's happening with
farmers and maybe there could be a food
shortage at some point back then they
wouldn't worry about that because they
were growing their own food you know
regarding this climate change fear that
they're telling farmers not to grow
fruit food i find this sad because
there's a lot of evidence that we can
withdraw the carbon from the atmosphere
i don't know if you've been following or
even with no farmers what's that with
more farming with more farming i don't
know plants absorb carbon that's one way
to do it but you can actually deposit
the carbon dioxide onto like palladium
or other metals and then withdraw the
graft the carbon from it and get
graphene just building materials but
they don't know it's like the the
politicians either don't know
i assume they don't know it's ignorance
because if they knew
there would be another discussion like
it's the most valuable resource on earth
this carbon and if we could just get it
back you can get it right out of the
smoke stack too well so uh do you uh do
do you know where the mass of a tree
comes from
i would the roots
no we're just breathing seriously i
don't know you guys know where like a
tree grows
right there's mass accumulating where
does that matter come from oh co2 that's
right because it comes from the air it
sucks out kind of what we consider
pollution what we consider pollution is
its life
the building blocks of a tree come from
the air it takes the carbon it builds
it's like how ours comes from the food
that we eat that's their food it's the
carbon dioxide well it's also water well
and they emit oxygen as well right we
kind of are they they take the carbon
dioxide and rip the carbon off and spit
the oxygen back out so when you have
farmers being told not to farm it's like
uh those crops actually absorb carbon
from the atmosphere why would you why
would you not want that now i can
understand concerns about nitrogen is
what they're they're saying i'm not
necessarily talking about carbon but we
want more plants to be growing so why
wouldn't just be like hey plant a bunch
of trees like you know allocate a
certain amount of time plant trees and
these places anyway look i'm not gonna
pretend to be an environmental expert so
i'm i'm sure whatever i said made no
sense some scientists probably like tim
you're wrong for these reasons like
government but don't you think that
there's not really
anything either exactly
position yeah what are we saying well i
think we all want a healthy environment
we want to have clean air clean water
but it's gotten to the point where it's
being pushed so much that it's
destroying our economy pushing companies
out oh you're going to pollute too much
too much co2 and the company finally
says you know we'll just move it to
china or india
and and then they take all those jobs
away they destroy all those families
they destroy a local economy
and you know talk about an animal in in
peril the human being and but yet the
environmentalists are okay with that
that company setting up a manufacturing
or factory in another country and
polluting there there was actually
in india are terrible about pollution
right and so so are you do you care
about the world the globe or don't you
i i i i want to pull the story if i have
to do it this this story infuriated me
to to to no one
yeah it's from me i'm sorry to interrupt
you but so this was great it's important
it's nearby mediaite says beltway
climate protest backfires as video of
parolee pleading he needs to get to work
goes viral these people are climate
change activists who blocked a highway
in maryland
a man gets out of his car and says
hey i gotta get to work i'm on parole if
i don't get to work i will be put back
in prison they don't say a word they
ignore them they don't care he says
please give me one lane let me go to
work they ignore him he starts yelling
at him ripping their signs the police
come in and arrest him yep here's the
here's i saw the video of them pulling
these guys off i thought it was great
i'm like pull each and every one of them
off and move the traffic he got arrested
he got arrested and then this guy
guido uh reichstager who was there
launched a fundraiser trying to raise a
hundred thousand dollars
saying help this man out he doesn't know
who the guy is he doesn't know the guy's
name he is trying to raise a hundred
grand off the back of a man whose life
he destroyed these people this is the
trolley problem
they would pull the lever to kill you in
a moment if they thought they were doing
good now here's the reality of it the
trolley problem presents you you guys
familiar with it right yeah we all love
the trolley problem there's five people
in the tracks the train's gonna come and
hit him if you pull the lever you kill
someone who is not in danger but it's
one person versus the five
you see that is a very simple way of
explaining these problems you can see
five people in danger you can see one
person not in danger would you pull the
lever the reality is these psychopathic
narcissists who would destroy your life
for their righteousness cannot see
anything you're right so here's the
better trolley problem a train is coming
the track is completely clear someone
runs up to you and says hey if that
train keeps going eventually someone
will die
now if you pull that lever and divert it
you'll kill that person
what do you say
that's what they're doing they know
they're destroying lives they know they
ruin this guy's life they're trying to
make money off of it a hundred grand he
doesn't know this guy is he's not gonna
be able to give him any money
and they don't know that climate change
is actually going to cause the problems
they think it's going to cause
no one is known as smart enough to
predict exactly how it will play out
well and there are solutions to climate
change are going to cause even more
drastic and horrible problems for
the world i believe so they don't really
care about people at all and they don't
care in in the same way that these biden
i guess voters who just hated trump
don't care about outcomes for for people
exactly and then
the fact that this man launched a
gofundme seeking a hundred grand is the
perfect example of who these people are
they don't care they hate trump and they
will try to make money off you mm-hmm
that's so brutal so aggressive i didn't
know that that had gone on that the man
was on parole he was going to a job he
had to show up at or he was going to get
thrown back behind bars if he didn't
show up to work on time
he get thrown he get thrown in jail and
he didn't drag i saw the video of him
like grabbing a sign but do they just
knock it out of their cars and just pull
the people off the street because it's a
type of assault i saw a woman there too
and i was actually going bravo get these
people off the road
and allow people to get moving
they may not have to work or they may
want to sit home and they may want to
cause trouble
but people have lives to live they have
children to feed
they have mouths to feed at home you
know what this is first i i respect
non-violent civil disobedience they want
to come and they want to block the
highway
bravo do your thing you got your
attention
attention congratulations the police
should then come in and arrest them
within a matter of minutes clear the
road you've made your point you got
arrested you cross it you cause a
traffic jam but everybody carries on and
their mind is a minor inconvenience the
police were not doing anything well cops
were letting them there's not a lot also
they've defunded the police the same
people wanted to fund the police i
didn't mind that somebody pulled them
off the road they didn't do it in a
violent way it's like dude this is a
road for traveling on take your protest
we get we get the idea move it along
right i didn't think pulling these guys
off the road was an act of violence when
you've got
thousands of cars backed up and the cops
just let them sit there so i'll tell you
something let's ramp up the fear so you
see how they treat this one man they
destroy his life they try to make money
off it greta tunberg famously said we
want to end fossil fuels now
paraphrasing we don't want to wait till
2030 we don't want to wait till 2023 we
want to end it now
do you know what happened if we shut off
fossil fuels like that right now
i think the estimate is 60 million
people die overnight
die overnight
yep i would think that at the econom
everything would collapse
without uh fossil fuels we don't have
electricity we're going to plastics
plastics are built from oil man that's
right
but the immediate the immediate reaction
is
without oil if if we just stopped all
use of oil right now
first diabetics they're they're they're
done because insulin is kept
refrigerated if they can't get power if
they don't have some kind of alternate
way of of you know backup power
they die
many people are reliant on heat from
fossil fuels in cold climates older
people they die
when you get these activists like greta
tunberg who outright ignore countries
like china or india and just rag on
europe and the united states say they
want to end it today you might think
oh she's just ignorant if only she knew
that what she was proposing would kill
millions of people she would not
advocate for it no no she would and they
do know and they do it anyway they made
her a celebrity and i mean they they put
at the top of the ticket for their
environmental you know ideas at the time
i think she was what 16 or 14 yeah
that was their spokesperson well you
know what i i strongly encourage all of
these young people to be like greta
tunberg drop out of school
hey i've met some smart people who
aren't in school i'm on the campaign
trail a lot of the smartest people i
meet the greatest kids i meet are the
ones that are homeschooled that's why
and you could like bottom from a mile
away i'm not sure that greta would be on
my list of smartest people but
i don't know her so i don't want to i
don't want to like what would greta even
say to those points you were making i
don't think she would know what to make
of them because she's so dumb hyper
fixated on this issue like it's a like
she does have autism and it is her
special interest
but it's being made into her career path
she was like these people have a fantasy
of unlimited economic growth
and i think she called it a fantasy and
it's like yes
because what we've discovered is that
while you can't keep building buildings
or producing widgets you can make
digital property and crypto and things
like that so we can have endless
economic growth when you have a virtual
uh we have a virtual world where you
have virtual goods that are just data in
a machine so you can actually uh there
there are people who used to have jobs
making warcraft gold
just playing a video game and then
giving the gold to someone else for
money you can produce things and have
economic growth that doesn't impact the
physical reality granted playing the
video game does have an impact with
electric uh electricity consumption and
things like that she clearly just
doesn't know what she's talking about
you can have unlimited economic growth
it's actually the nature of our species
and reality is unlimited economic stuff
but it's the rate of economic expansion
that state can become dangerous you
don't want it to grow too fast too or
maybe you do because uh you know as the
story goes back in the turn of the
century 1900s there were these reports
in all these big newspapers that we were
gonna have a manure crisis in new york
city that there was gonna be horse
manure piling up in the streets it would
be so much you wouldn't be able to get
around anymore and nobody would live
there and then the car got invented yeah
same thing with carbon in the air right
now it would imagine if they went back
and killed all the horses because they
were like no no more horse manure we
need to stop horses now it would have
been tragic the same thing with trying
to stop carbon producing machines well
you'll you're left but aoc put out a
green new deal thanks to farting cows
remember that yep yep farting farting
houses
they had more common sense back then
though they didn't have this lunacy back
then i think if we can get i like alex
alexandria or ocasio-cortez because i
feel like she's at least real a real
person whether or not she's misguided or
not she's at least like a real normal
person but like if you talk to her about
carbon recapture tech and you lay out
the graphene production in the industry
that we could create i think you could
bridge a gap between climate activists
and national industrialists we could
make the united states the greatest
industry on earth just making the
cheapest graphene to make you know 21st
century industry right and clean up the
air and live in synergy without
preserving the planet or cleaning up the
air
i think greta's cause
is really just to lower the standard
quality of life in the west and
reserve
you know things like meat and air
conditioning and flying on planes for an
elite club look what she did when she
was like i'm going to go to the the u.n
and take a boat instead of flying and
then she went on this really expensive
fiberglass ship with a crew that kept
her safe and it was like i forgot how
much it cost to do this journey but it
was a huge stunt that consumed way more
carbon than actually just flying all
about resource hoarding yep it's a
scarcity mindset
i do believe she she's been used by her
surroundings like her parents i think
kind of pushed her in that direction and
then because they're entertainers
but but i got i got to push back aoc is
not a real person
relative to most people in congress
that's what i mean i think she's here
she's she goes on
a lot of people and people think they
have a friendship with her because she's
in her kitchen and she's having wine and
making dinner and they go oh she's my
friend and that's where she's been able
to connect with people and and young
people
and this is where we're l and i do
believe we're seeing a a huge movement
of young people getting into politics
because they realize the last few years
of politics affects their lives
it affects their lives it affects their
ability to interact with the masks on
their face and all of the shutdowns and
the force vaccines and all that i know i
can't say that i'm sorry
but um
you know she got was able to get young
people involved in politics i think she
is leading them astray but what we're
seeing now is a huge movement of young
people and i think they're becoming
conservative because they're looking at
who tortured them the last three years
which party was torturing them who was
behind some of this and we're seeing it
in our campaign we're seeing a lot of
young people coming in and getting
involved i think they're going to vote
in droves well mary you're a young
person what do you think
well the left is obviously outdone the
right by miles
in
having their finger on the pulse of
culture
and the right is only just now catching
up
um and
it really hits on what you said about
like the masks because that's i think
when it touched a lot of people's
personal lives for the first time that's
like
it is literally right in your face
muzzling yeah hand over your mouth
and they were told by by social media
and the entertainment world this is good
you're doing a good thing but in their
brain they're thinking
okay all of the people in my social
world the celebrities who i like are
telling me this is good and we need to
do this but deep down in their heart
they went this sucks yeah young people
are hungry
but do do you think
the the
gen z is going to
so i want to make sure i clarify
republicans have more kids than than
democrats liberals conservatives have
more kids than than liberals do and so
there's more gen z conservatives by a
tiny bit according to pew but in general
among like normie gen z do you think
they're like
leaning more
anti-establishment anti-woke not
necessarily right-wing
or do you think they're left can you ask
it are they leaning more biden because
biden's that's right yeah because i
think they're seeing him as very uncool
i don't know am i right or wrong it
depends like who who does gen z want to
make the butt of their jokes that's like
really what you have to watch because
humor is all they have i don't think
they're leaning
any direction
they're kind of just hopeless and
uh
hopeless
yeah yeah i mean their sense of humor is
like
this post post post ironic
yeah
it's so nihilistic
uh i think they're
like alienated from
well they should vote for politics they
should it's very it's very late 1920s it
feels like weimar germany where they
needed a villain they needed a butt for
their joke and hitler pointed them at
the jews and then they had their villain
like we need to be careful and it's not
just
they hate themselves too like i feel so
sad when i see uh people a little bit
younger than me out in public because
they just look so uncomfortable in
themselves and i think the pandemic
really exacerbated that um because they
were socially isolated
they
got a terrible education
over a screen
for years um thankfully i was spared
from that but um it's going to be really
weird
because there's this this covid period
is going to have a profound impact on
people even though it's only a couple
years so you've got millennials and
older
who lived a life outside of the
lockdowns until the lockdowns happened
so they were adults but then you've got
gen z and jen alpha who
developmental years were happening
in this lockdown period which is going
to like scramble their brain
this is really this is where oh my gosh
as a mom i'm just
very sad about what happened what we did
to our kids and just listening to you
talk about
in their sense of humor we tortured our
children
and it's not the moms who did it we but
a lot of moms and dad felt like they
were being forced to abuse their
children every day having to put a mask
on their four-year-old and send them off
or the parents who were on planes and
they were like put the mask on your
one-year-old and they were like they
keep taking it off and they're like
don't care get off then yeah it's just
like and it's forcing these parents who
love more than anything this child to do
something they know is wrong and it is
sick as hell
and we will never ever forget that
what are your thoughts on homeschooling
i love it i mean i'm out in the campaign
trail and i can spot a homeschool kid
from a mile away they come up they talk
to you they look in the eye i'll say are
you homeschooled per chance and they're
like yeah i am been homeschooled and
then the mom will say i'm homeschooling
them for three years started with covid
and um really bright kids really right
isn't it crazy that
the institutionalized learning
facilities funded by our taxpayer
dollars are stunting children and
inhibiting them and that you can see it
in a homeschooled kid that they're
better adjusted more mature you know the
the school what they call the teachers
union they're having their national um
you know meeting right now and they're
can you believe they're trying to push
for masks again
wow this is sick it's absolutely safe in
the public schools yeah that's one of
their agenda items it's like are you
serious are you really do you want
nobody going to your school we just
passed uh the biggest school choice bill
into law
uh in this last session in the last
couple weeks that the money follows the
student arizona is the leader in this
now so if you've got ian has a son or
daughter and you don't like what they're
teaching in school up the road you say
you know what we're taking the money our
tax money we're going to this school and
it's huge so this is this is the
craziest thing i'm a huge fan of school
choice
because uh we we saw the supreme court
ruling up in maine for instance where
they said in certain areas of maine they
don't have public schools
so the taxpayer is given essentially a
voucher to choose where they want to go
maine was like okay but you can't go to
religious institutions supreme court
said you can't do that that's that's
meddling that's you know but you could
right
so now we're so we see that the left
freaks out we see uh in florida i think
florida just did a school choice thing
or they're moving towards it and they
i'm wondering how are the democrats
going to try and spin school choice as a
bad thing
and what they're saying is
republicans are going to enact school
choice
then
once parents start leaving public
schools they're going to say oh look
nobody needs public schools and they're
going to shut them all down
so that kids are dumb it's the weirdest
non-argument the reality is there's no
argument against school choice it makes
no sense
there's public schools
parents get a choice in which public
school they go to if you poll people on
this
it's overwhelming democrat independent
and republicans want it so you go well
how come it's taken this long to get it
because the democrats are getting money
from the teachers union a lot of money
is at stake here um
this money does not belong to the public
schools
the the money we pour in for education
belongs to the students it's for the
students and for a long time they've
convinced people it belongs to the
public schools no that money we are
taxed and that money goes set aside to
educate our students
it doesn't mean it goes to the public
school there's nothing that says it goes
to the public school if republicans and
conservatives win on the school front
they win period it's over
liberals are not having kids
conservatives are even having less kids
but they have way more so the only way
in the next 10 to 20 years the
conservatives lose is if they don't
inspire young people
so
people really need to think about this
too because so many people don't
10 years ago we've got barack obama's
second term right and you you were how
old you were like 11
yeah not even voting you're just trying
to make me feel old over here with her
well we're old too but my point is
you got to understand 10 years goes in
the blink of an eye
i mean
i i can't believe occupy wall street was
was 11 years ago it's 11 years that's
that's crazy and the the political
issues that we were dealing with that we
were concerned about
gen z has no idea what any of that is
so you don't know anything about occupy
wall street i'd imagine right i don't
mean that in a disrespectful way i mean
like you were a little kid you probably
weren't paying attention yeah i mean
after the fact i i've heard about it
sure but
at the time no idea so this is something
that's come up on the show and we had um
i think it was vosh socialist we had him
on the show hunter avalon too young
hunter avalon yeah well it was vosh as
well oh was it really i think both ages
they yeah they're similar ages and
because they're in their 20s and i said
i don't understand how people could be
could vote for joe biden after
everything we went through during the
obama era and with with you know during
occupy wall street obama was the bad guy
obama was the bailout guy i know you can
blame george bush for a lot of the stuff
too you go back to 2000 but obama was
was was obama the drone guy and the
response we get from him is oh i was in
high school i don't know any of that
stuff i never thought of that you're
right
so i have no idea so here's what happens
conservatives have a bunch of kids
elon musk he's cranking out the babies
that that's the first thing because
those kids are going to retain some of
the values of their parents some
many of these parents are taking their
kids and they're putting them into
institutionalized learning facilities
that hate you
that want to indoctrinate your kids if
the conservatives win on school choice
it's done
the left their dogma their cult will die
with them as they age and they lose
voting power
and the new generation raised by
typically raised by conservatives will
retain conservative values give it 20
years and we're going to see two
generations step up into the vote to
voting age and if the conservatives keep
having their kids and protecting them
from these institutionalized learning
facilities the united states hands down
becomes a christian conservative nation
now i'm not saying it's a good thing for
those that aren't christian conservative
but that's what will happen if christian
conservative parents instill their
values in their kids that's interesting
do you know that uh since the roe v wade
news uh the rate of vasectomies has like
skyrocketed and i'm sure every
conservative is laughing and high-fiving
their friends
because they're the anti-life side
sadly if you i i said this ten years ago
to people i said it a few years ago
if you are
even one percent more likely to get an
abortion
let's say you have 100 let's say you
have 50 democrats and 50 conserva
republicans
and the democrats are one percent more
likely to have an abortion over a long
enough period of time the democrats will
cease to exist and the republicans will
keep having kids because it's just basic
math but it doesn't matter it's not just
abortion though they're also i'm hearing
a lot of people saying that are liberals
saying i don't want to have kids because
of the climate change and i'm just
worried about the climate
they have been brainwashed into thinking
that it's a bad idea to have children
and it's one of the greatest gifts
that i believe god gives you is when he
makes you a parent well they're also uh
some of these parents are sterilizing
their kids
oh with the the puberty blocks
transgender stuff puberty blockers
things like that and doctors who go
along with that um really we need to
look at their medical license it's what
the surgeries especially are especially
minors so you look at where we're going
and this is why i stress again the
school issue is the most important i
don't know if conservatives totally get
it the way you uh that is a great point
i mean that was that was deep and that
was true the saying is
socialists don't have kids they have
yours
if people are conservative and they have
kids and they put them in a college
don't be surprised when your young
beautiful blonde daughter comes home
with a shaved head tattoos gauges and is
screaming that you're evil
this is the craziest thing because i've
seen these stories where a guy you know
he posted on reddit and he's like my
daughter came back from college and she
hates me i don't understand yeah and it
takes they go there in august and by
thanksgiving they come back and they've
changed yep
gotta protect them yeah i think it's
great and we're on the way we're doing
great things in arizona the charter move
school movement really began and we are
going to be the school i call it school
freedom education freedom state and any
way we can make that better so that our
kids are getting a quality education not
a brainwashing and in my plan for
education is we have what we'd like to
push is a dual track education so after
10th grade you decide hey we're going to
go the the four-year college route or do
we want to go and get skills training
trade school vocational certification
there's no reason we can't get our kids
out of school at 18 and have them ready
to take on the world most of these jobs
don't require college as a matter of
fact college sets you back from
achieving the american dream because
you're in a heap of debt and look at you
know what do we say 18 years old james
monroe these young founding fathers of
ours were doing big things created a
country yeah it took on a monarchy yeah
wow yeah so we need to get our kids
ready at 18. i talk to industry leaders
every week and they say we've got great
jobs they pay 80 000 full benefits you
know what nobody to fill them you know
what kids need
jobs
the jobs are out there but they're not
ready for them and we should get them
ready in high school i mean
children need jobs oh and but i'll
clarify too because i know that the left
loses their minds because some
republicans said that and they're like
child labor in the mines oh man we
worked so hard as kids i mean up at 6 00
a.m on the weekend chores it was crazy
exactly so i worked at my family's
business my mom opened a cafe didn't
survive all that long but a couple years
and i think i worked something like 10
hours a week
working with the family business
that is what kids need you don't want
kids doing back breaking labor you don't
working in factories and anything crazy
like that i was making sandwiches and
ringing ringing up people's coffee but
you want some responsibility you can do
some back breaking work there's not a
damn thing wrong with that oh no no of
course of course like i mean dad's dad's
teaching their kid to chop lumber yeah
kids mowing the lawn kids carrying stuff
and moving bricks that's all fine i'm
just like industrial machinery there's a
reason why we said hey we don't want the
kids well we don't want our kids going
off to work in a factory at age 9 and
10. no but we wanted
my dad would wake us up we heated our
home partially in the winter with wood
and so we had to you know split wood and
cut down trees and do all that and it
was puppets
at the time i dreaded it i'm sure i
complained the entire day we'd get up at
six a.m we're there you know what we
were paid
a soda we'd go to the gas station after
we were done and we would you know put
you know whatever it was at the time 50
cents or whatever into the you know pop
machine and that was our pay for working
from like
six to three or four in the afternoon
cutting wood cutting lumber and then
splitting wood and loading wood into the
truck and then unloading the wood but
i'm so glad i have
um that understanding of how do you do
that kids need work they need to you
know paper routes they used to do we
don't have that anymore we need things
like that the greatest thing about a
paper route
it was the collection part do you
remember i mean i don't know if you're
old enough to remember that the paper
boy would you know ride his bike throw
the paper and then at the end of the
week when we were little he'd have to
come knocking at the door and collect
you know whatever the payment was for
the paper that week yeah can you imagine
you're doing like you know debt
collection at age 10
when i was i was a kid we would go
door-to-door mowing lawns and shoveling
snow
that was like a normal thing where i
grew up so whenever would snow we'd be
we'd get excited and be like let's go
make some money we can make some dough
yeah and then we'd knock and like you
know some middle-aged dude would come
out and we'd be like we want to can we
shovel your walkway for money and it's
like i gave you 10 bucks and we're like
yes got it that's awesome i wonder do
kids still do that did you do that do
you know anybody who does that my
brothers definitely did yeah yeah that's
good things like that are good kids need
that stuff i wish we would have done
more of that with our kids if they're
watching they're probably like mom
please don't talk about us don't but we
didn't push that we didn't have to do
that with our kids and i i regret that
we weren't pushing more of of you know
work around the house and things like
that both of my kids do work so that's
great
um but they're just so afraid to let
their kids out of the bubble i think
that's it the stranger danger is huge
now oh yeah i never really taught my
kids that because i didn't want them to
look around and be afraid of people i
mean there are obviously bad people in
this world in the public schools i
wanted to know if they ever got lost and
where you know you're at a ballpark or
whatever and they got lost i wanted them
to know that you know what 99.9 of the
people
if you just go up and ask them for help
are going to be helpful so i always
train them go find another mommy yes and
tell her you're lost but don't panic
just find another mommy and she'll help
fight you know because i always knew
another mom would help if they see a
child
are your kids adults yeah my son is 17
and my daughter is 19. let's talk about
their
future
we have this story from the washington
examiner arizona attorney general seeks
invasion status to tackle illegal
immigration
i saw a video of thousands of people
marching through central america and
south america and mexico carrying the
flags of their own countries
as they try they announced they were
coming to the united states and then
when the conservatives were saying it
was an invasion the media on the left
said that it was hate speech that it was
a talking point and i'm just sitting
here like
i don't know man i saw a video of like a
thousand people carrying the flags of
their own country trying to come to ours
and then i watched them attack border
guards
so i kind of feel like
look you you might not like the idea of
the word but it qualifies it's truly an
invasion anybody who says it isn't
either is uneducated
or lying
i've been down on the border there are
people coming over all day every day and
sometimes in small groups of 9 and 10
sometimes 250 rush the border
we see the video there
well at least now we know if they've got
the flag which country to send them back
to because we can't absorb them here in
we're not going to absorb them in
arizona so uh mark brnovich is that i
pronounce it is calling on governor doug
ducey to uh invoke invasion status and
take action
two questions i suppose do you think it
will happen and if you were governor
would you do it yeah we should have done
it a long time ago in the beginning of
january i put together my border policy
and the first thing you do is you issue
a declaration of invasion
and invoke basically your article 1
section 10
rights as a state to protect your people
when you're in danger and you have an
invasion and you have to declare the
invasion to kind of get that ball
rolling i gave my plan to governor ducey
and i said please take this you can have
it you can rename it you can call the
ducey plan whatever but do it you can't
wait until i'm governor in january 23.
we can't go another year
with thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people pouring across the
cartels being in control the drugs
pouring across killing and weakening
americans
uh we can't do it and he's done nothing
he's done nothing he's done nothing no
and then he you know
he'll do a dog and pony show at the
border and it's like
do you not see what's happening here do
you not care about arizona i don't know
if it's because he's a lame duck and
it's going to take too much work but
we're going to on day one i'll take my
hand off the bible after the oath of
office and we're going to issue a
declaration of invasion we're going to
put the arizona national guard at the
border and we're going to arm them and
we're going to stop people from coming
across unfortunately the border patrol
can't do that
they're under joe biden right they're
federal and they're forced to just
process these people and they come over
with smiles on their face they're like
wow land of the free here we are
and it's destroying the middle class
these what's really sad if you really
can care about people
if you really care about people and are
compassionate these people coming over
millions of them are basically
indentured servants to the cartels
you come over and you owe the cartel for
your passage into america and it's
thousands of dollars you've got to work
to pay off
sometimes they never can because much
like student loan debts for instance
they say you're going to owe us more
there's going to be interest you'll
never be able to pay it off this was a
wristband given to me by jorge ventura
from it was on one of the i guess you
call them migrants one of the uh
this is entregas which means delivered
they were being delivered by cartel they
were they they they were the labels four
one eight six is the number but that was
for that was for children
this is what's oh there's children's
shoes everywhere i just got chills
actually thinking about the last time i
was there children's clothes children's
shoes
um children coming across something is
deeply wrong with this country when you
have a political faction of millions of
voters who would
protect these people the cartels protect
the coyotes you remember when donald
trump was debating and he said the
coyotes are bringing people across and
these blue checkmark journalists did not
know what a coyote was and they all
laughed and thought trump was talking
about animals because they weren't smart
enough to google search to know what
that means yeah you have young girls
being abused by human traffickers
and it's because joe biden will not deal
with this and you know you know what
biden did instead of securing the border
he started putting these miners on
planes and flying them across the
country to sweep it under the rug oh you
see it every every time we fly out we
flew here and you see people in the
airport they don't have id they just
have their basically their court
paperwork to show up at court that's we
have to show our id you know hand over
everything and they're they're all over
the airport
and they're being shipped to a city near
you and this is why
people from all 50 states have gotten
involved in our campaign because they
know
we are going to protect the border in
arizona and this is a national issue not
an arizona issue it's a national issue
and if we don't get strong governors in
our border states we're gone we're done
as a country if there's an invasion
status declared and they get armed can
they just mow down civilians no and
that's not what we're doing i mean this
is kind of what the liberals will say
what do you want to we want our our
arizona national guard and our guard
members and we're going to ask other
states to send their guard down as well
we need boots on the ground to protect
our our border
this is to protect our our national
guard we're dealing with the cartels
you know you don't have to watch that
many issues of any any movie dealing
with a cartel breaking bad they're
they're not friendly people okay we're
not going to have our guard members be
killed while they're down there
protecting us and we're just going to
stop people when we catch them we're
going to process them and we're sending
them back and we have a couple of brave
sheriffs in texas you've been following
that they finally are saying hey we want
to declare an invasion if our governor
won't do it we will do it and one of
them
had processed some people they were
involved in an accident or something and
they refused service they refused going
to the hospital and so he took him and
he drove him right back to the port of
entry dropped him off and said wow adios
so we have this story from tim cass tech
center gov texas governor abbott
authorizes national guard dps to arrest
illegal migrants and return them to the
border i don't think he he he didn't
declare invasion but he's getting you
know he's kind of on the edge sending
the national guard out to deal with this
what do you what do you think of what
he's doing you think he's doing a well
enough job he's getting pressured the
people are going come on what how how
much worse does this have to get
before we see these governors grow a
spine i mean
why aren't they doing it how hard is it
i i think our government's uh part and
parcel to this i mean i think the
federal government the last time i was
there i watched three van loads of
illegals being brought in
and the
border agent stopped with the third van
he rolled the window down he said i'm
voting for you but you've got to stop
this this is the 2873rd
illegal alien i've processed and this
was early in may this was like the first
week
2873rd illegal alien i've processed at
this spot
that's one guy
and he said it's got to stop and he's
right i don't know why our governors
aren't doing anything
other than they're weak or maybe they're
open borders types maybe they want to
see this big global agenda i don't know
but i do know this
it's going to stop and it's going to
stop in january of 2023
and
we are going to win this election
oh yeah that's why they're that's why
they're writing hit pieces every week
that's why they're attacking me that's
why they're going so hard i think i'm
their least favorite person other than
donald trump right now because they know
i'm not in politics because i want a
career in politics i'm in politics
because i'm a fed up mom who's sick of
seeing our state being trampled
and is sick of seeing the crime and the
drugs come in i want to get in there
stop this insanity and get back to my
life
what do you think about ron desantis
love him
we need more governors like him as well
and if we're going to get one right from
the
sound of it it's fascinating how the
never trumper types uh chris ruffo
you're familiar with christopher ruffo
no who is that he's uh how would you
describe him one of the leading
academics on critical race theory and
gender ideology critical race theory
stuff in the pacific northwest for like
years now it's great he said that
desantis is basically the litmus test
for never trumpers because they should
support him he's uh got military
experience he's a
he's well spoken he's not you know crass
he's conservative it's wonderful and
they don't he's effective right
but so why is it that these
never trumper conservatives don't
support desantis they have no good
reason
like trump and desantis and even
christie gnome to to an extent and and
like i'm going to be we are going to be
effective and we're going to show how
worthless
this last generation of politicians have
been
trump exposed all of that he made
everyone look like a big fool
they made us believe that it took 20
years to get one little thing done a
bridge built the money for a bridge to
be built i mean we had a town in arizona
that a big community where
every time it rained
the road would flood and you couldn't
pass it you couldn't pass over going
from one side of town to the other and
so you had to take a 40-mile detour they
were begging begging begging
for federal dollars to build a bridge so
that this town basically could function
when it rained
it took them 20 years
it took i think dozens of people had to
die in that flooded road and that's what
we were we were taught that that's how
long it takes the federal government
it's like a cold day molasses flowing on
a cold day you can't get anything done
trump goes in and boom right away he
says all these promises and everyone
said he'll never do it boom he starts
going down his to-do list and gets
everything done while he's being
simultaneously attacked by the swamp
attacked by the media and we realized oh
my gosh
he's the he's the effective one these
other people are just lifers who are
you know don't care about us it'd be
cool if when you're governor if you have
like a local state thing where people in
their localities can vote even like on
an app or something to redirect a
portion of their tax funds their state
tax funds to like local issues
and then if they can get enough people
to to swipe right on their issue and
allocate like one percent so like a
tinder for tax money this this is
actually uh is that what tinder is
exactly swipe left
i love this idea the general idea is
obviously you can't do with all taxes
but there could be like a certain
percentage where it's like let's see how
the people feel about these issues
and you could be like download the app
take the survey and the vote on what
issue you think and then we'll show
everybody how everyone on the app voted
and then
is it
swipe right or left is yes swipe right
that's the difficult thing okay swipe
right is good yes of course the right
but the the bottom thing is difficult
right is correct bots that's difficult
yeah you'd have to like sign up with
your social security number you know be
like a you'd be a citizen you'd have
local whatever that's great
we could do that wouldn't it be nice if
we did that with federal money i wonder
how many people would have swiped right
for the 58 billion going to ukraine yeah
and in those situations i imagine we
would still have like black budget
thirty percent you're not allowed to
spend less than that like like you just
have to accept fire department police
department it's gonna be great out at
seven percent but there could be stuff
like new skateboarding you could put
more
i guarantee you the wall would have been
built a long time ago yeah and i'll
guarantee you ukraine would not be
taking our tax money it works with like
popular support i mean we are a popular
support
government it's you vote to get the
people in if you could vote for the
things you want as well that's the
appearance let's let's uh uh let's let's
ju jump to this story
um carrie you said that uh you're
getting the trump treatment
i got the washington post after me you
got the washington post after you and
they wrote this they published this
opinion piece please republicans don't
nominate carrie lake for arizona
governor you know what i i as soon as i
see that i put on my they live
sunglasses
and i can see them saying
help us please if this woman actually
wins and starts going after the
establishment
when i see a story that's the washington
post my immediate reaction is
i'm going to do the opposite of what
you're basically it's like they're using
reverse
i just got indoors
yeah who do they think they are this is
the best endorsement you can get
washington post being like no yes and
then our local paper which is the most
liberal reg in you know west of the
mississippi is saying you've got to do
to please independents get into a vote
against her
i'm not radical i'm america first so let
me let me read this portion it says you
can see this for yourself
her campaign launch video featured her
hitting tvs with a sledgehammer and
burning face masks
all right okay that's i love it i mean
even what a sledgehammer like whatever
your opinion is on masks it's like are
you telling people like smashing tvs
just sounds like sounds like james okay
i'm smashing the fake news is what i was
doing
her fourth of july celebration rally was
held at a gun range where attendees were
offered a chance to fire a machine gun
okay that's awesome that sounds so cool
on monday she tweeted f and i cannot
stress this enough jp
it's read f and i cannot stress this
enough jb
in response to the news that the justice
department is suing arizona over its new
election law lake's outrageous
showmanship apparently knows no bounds
the washington post was purchased by
jeff bezos it is the establishment mega
corporation nightmare dystopian
embodiment and
when they say don't do something it's
the thing you need to do
absolutely when i saw that i'm like oh
my gosh i think that might push us right
over the edge and we'll win i want to
tell you you know
i hear you talking about the border and
america first and these things and i
know deep down there's a lot of people
who are probably like how much of this
do you actually mean and how much is
just rhetoric and to be fair in my
younger days i i like
when trump was running i didn't care i'd
vote for anybody
but i got to be honest seeing trump
seeing ron desantis kind of put the fire
back in me where i actually believe that
we can win and elect people who are
actually going to do what they want what
they say they're going to do
i'm absolutely going to do what i say
i'm going to do that's why
dr evil's newspaper is that we call him
jeff bezos dr evil um that's why
they're afraid of me that's why they're
going i've never seen a barrage of
negative media most of it lies
after one person since president trump
they're so
worried about us because they know i
can't be bought i can't be bribed i mean
i walked away from my money money means
nothing first of all they're printing it
they're trying to devalue the dollar and
and crash the economy
what good is a paycheck what good is all
of that if we don't have a country we're
at the point right now i used to say the
11th hour i think we're in the final
minutes
of the existence of america if we don't
get in there and do some really bold big
things and that's why they're scared to
death of me and they're writing these
articles because i am going to do what i
say i'm going to do
well so yeah you have this uh
what would you describe this as like a
little poster about your your opponent
yeah karen taylor robson
arizona's most liberal republican
so
the one thing that immediately strikes
me is anti-second amendment
oh but she tries to say she's pro 2a but
she when she here's the thing doug ducey
our our governor
appointed her to the board of regents
that's the governing board for all of
our state universities
and while there she voted
to expand expand expand these gun-free
zones i don't even call them that
they're they're sitting duck zones our
children are sitting ducks in these gun
free zones whenever you see gun free
zone
you know that you don't you're not
protected
and you know let me let's face it
arizona's universities are growing asu
is a big universe i think is the biggest
one in the country now
and they're moving it outside it used to
be just kind of in tempe that's grown
grown grown now they've got a campus in
downtown
phoenix
they've got one in mesa they've got one
all over and that's great i'm all for
that but i'm not for walking through
downtown phoenix in an open carry state
i'm carrying my sidearm i walk across
the street to go get a coffee and all of
a sudden i don't have second amendment
rights yeah that's crazy and that's what
gun-free zones are and she tries to act
like she cares about her second
amendment do people genuinely believe
that the criminal who wants to cause
harm to someone is going to walk up the
sign sitting there creates some kind of
force field that stops them from
penetrating the street
what's happening that'd be a good comic
to show strip after strip of the guy
like prepping for the killing you know
he's like getting his guns ready he's
loading his guns he's looking at social
media and then he goes to the place and
he sees the sign and he looks all sad
and turns away
i think it was texas again that i saw um
the sign at a school that said we have
armed people in this school
don't come in i mean if you're going to
come in and try to cause problems you're
going out in either a body bag or a
stretcher but you're not going to come
in here and hurt us
and that's what we need actually we need
armed security we have armed security
everywhere in this country you go to a
basketball game you go to a mall
businesses have armed security where i
used to work at armed security but we
don't have arm security for our little
babies at the very least do not
publicize that it's a disarmed area
that's insane that's so crazy you at
least want to lie about it and pretend
like you don't have weapons when you do
or you do when you don't right in a
gun-free zone
where people don't have guns
when a bad person defies the sign
and enters with a gun
who do the administrators call
people with guns somebody with a gun to
come and help them and every single
incident throughout all time
the only way you stop somebody who's
killing with a gun is somebody who's got
a gun to stop them or another weapon to
stop them well you you could have like a
a crack team of special agents who like
climb through the vents and then jump
down and like put them kind of like in
the movies like in the movies but i
would just say realistically it's people
being armed even with armed security
think about parkland
their armed security didn't save them
and then
uh yuvaldi they called the cops the cops
didn't help them
it was i think that moms and dads were
trying to get in moms and dads were
trying to get in armed texans were
trying to get in some did the cops were
stopping them
so
the the the administration of the law as
as they've been doing it clearly isn't
working
we the people need to protect ourselves
and that's why we need the second second
amendment i truly believe that the only
reason we have a country right now
because everything else has fallen to
pieces is because that second amendment
it's the only thing keeping us a country
right now we don't have freedom of
speech our first amendment rights have
been trampled our churches got shut down
i know uh i don't feel like i have
freedom of speech like some people do
everywhere i go i ask people how do you
feel about your first amendment rights
are they fully intact do you have them
do you have perfect first amendment
rights right now and nobody raises
yourself
where's the redress of grievances
you know how do we how do we handle that
because that doesn't seem to be
happening no you're right yeah but our
second amendment is what's keeping us a
country minute they take that and
they're trying right now we do crumble
and we will not give those rights up and
i you know i'm i'm not speaking like a
normal politician i'm i'm not a
politician i guess they can call me that
now
and so i don't pull things before i ask
but i do look to the constitution and
this we're not letting go of
they can try and they say oh it was
written by slave owner i mean all this
garbage they're trying to say about our
constitution
and this is the only document that we
should be looking to to save our country
right now a lot of people have talked
about national divorce what are your
thoughts on that have you heard people
talking about tell me what that is i've
heard a little bit about it
well there are people who believe that
we're headed towards a civil war unless
there's an amicable split and these
these blue states just form their own
union and the red states form their own
union
so this the peaceful divorce that people
have referred to it as
i think you go back to sovereign states
and then you decide where you want to
live if you want if what you see in
california is is what you like then you
stay there
if you don't you go to a state like
arizona and that's is i don't know if
that's what you're referring to as a
national divorce but that's a great way
that's federalism right yeah the idea
that the states are sovereign as a
weaker federal government and
that's great i actually support that the
issue is
right now the democrats are losing their
minds because the supreme court said we
do not have the authority to dictate
what states do as it pertains to
abortion
congress would have to codify something
for the time being it's to the states
so you have activists in blue states
demanding that red states live the way
they want them to live
if you have
arizona or texas or florida saying you
guys do your thing and we'll do ours but
then california illinois and new york
are saying no you will do as you're told
then it seems inevitable there's going
to be some kind of
clash
you can't you can't function that way
right
no you can you just say well i'm sorry
you feel that way but we're going to do
our thing we're going to do the arizona
way but this so this would be are you
suggesting they're going to take uh you
know
violence against us because we're doing
things the arizona way it just it gets
to a point where the federal government
is is shown to have the emperor has no
clothes right i suppose the the lightest
uh view of it would be the supreme court
says what california or not even supreme
court what california is doing with an
immigration sanctuary state they're
letting these people come in here's the
problem
california is allowing illegal
immigrants in mass they're giving them
free health care
in new york they're even trying to give
them the right to vote they got blocked
by a judge
presidential votes go through the
electoral college congress
our laws in this country
go through congressional districts
congressional districts are set not by
the amount of citizens but by the amount
of people in general so when california
allows non-citizens in they get more
presidential votes and they get more
votes in congress
stealing the rights of say the people of
arizona
that is a problem
and so you you now recently california's
lost ton of of their population so
they've actually they're coming to
arizona
yeah they lost the congressional seat
but you look at what some of these
states are doing when they're like we
will not abide by federal law
and eventually it starts breaking down i
don't know where it goes but i also know
that in uh new hampshire i think it's
new hampshire so you're not saying the
the
illegal population grows and the illegal
population is voting they're you know
not allowed to vote they don't need to
vote even though the department of
justice is trying to fight us on that in
arizona right now we will fight them
right back
but you're saying just the population
growth when we do the census gives them
a free congressional seat a new seat
yeah and it was just uh just before the
latest census california i believe was
estimated to have one extra
congressional seat based on allowing
illegal immigrant immigrants in the
state that means the citizens of texas
of arizona of florida
lose voting power at the federal level
because the members of congress is
locked in
they lose representational power because
of non-citizens being illegal this is
why president trump wanted to have that
question on the census that's right
and it's a fair question
it's a fair question it does hurt other
states
and um
he wasn't allowed to do that think about
who fought him on that yep
it's it's it's
interesting if non-citizens no matter
what state they're in just add to the
whole so just add to the you know so
like if every state has 150th and then
you get 7000 new immigrants going to one
state illegally it just adds to the
150th across the board no one state gets
to benefit from well that's the senate
the non-citizens that's the senate well
i'm talking about just for congressional
seats in general congrat congressional
seats are they do the census and then it
it's it increases every time it's like
770 000 people per district on average
or something like that because people
are there's more people we grew
we had a huge population growth and we
did not get an extra seat
uh people we really expected to get a
10th congressional seat when we didn't i
i still think there was something
uh not quite right about that people
need to understand that california sends
what how many do they have like 35
is it how many how many congressional
districts do they have do you know i
don't know
uh look it up they they said somebody
get on it yeah they send maybe it's 37.
let's see what you got what's the number
fact check
i'm so glad i learned how to type in
high school that's one of those skills
you need right so fast i mean that's one
of the greatest uh classes i took as
well it reduced from 53 seats to 52. i
was wrong 52
wow what was 53 you just flipped them
you said 35. this is probably the 2020
census sending 52 people to vote in
congress and you're wondering why it is
democrats have so much power in congress
california is not cooperating on
immigration laws they're offering
benefits to non-citizens like health
care and schooling they're incentivizing
more people to come then the census
happens then they're given an extra
congressional seat they get more voting
power by allowing people to come in and
break federal law
the federal government can't enforce
that law without the citizens of local
enforcement in california won't do it
this is evil dark stuff and the point is
at a certain point
the people of any other state are going
to say why did we lose this vote
in the federal at the federal level on
say gun control by one to california
those votes came from people who aren't
citizens
the people that they're representing
aren't even citizens that's what you're
saying exactly i think i think a
solution is i'll reiterate like if 50
new people going to california that are
not citizens every state gets one of
them towards their census i think the
solution is let's follow our immigration
laws we've got plenty of them on the
books we're not following them
and no longer allow illegal immigration
this is pretty basic stuff secure the
border president trump was trying to get
us there ask those questions on the
census so we know how many illegal
immigrants are living there you don't
get to count them in that well uh i i
hear what ian's saying
i hear your idea like if 100 if 50
illegal immigrants go to california then
every state gets to count one of those
people towards their state yes here's
what we got to do on the census we need
them to fill out a question as to
whether or not they're citizens
otherwise they could lie though well
otherwise we wouldn't no so donald trump
oh you know what he would have done that
when he said he wanted the citizenship
question on the uh census and they
blocked him and said he couldn't do it
how insane is that that's because they
didn't want ice to go round people up
and rip up families basically uh i think
it was more what is what what is the job
of ice
go break up families and send people out
of the country break up families well
rip up what is the legitimate actual job
description for to throw illegal
immigrants out of the country
essentially it is immigration and
customs enforcement yeah so sometimes
there's an is a person who's not a
citizen who kills someone they go and
arrest him it's not about hunting down
anybody or breaking up well if they know
someone's there illegally then they have
a duty to go and force the law extricate
them to enforce them and force the law
well they should enforce the law uh in
certain situations but in some
situations when the kid's been born in
the united states is 17 years old and
the monster you're born in the u.s an
illegal citizen yeah but if the mom's 50
and not you go there and remove a
50-year-old mom and then the 17 year old
has no mother like that's
unethical at least you could argue
i think the challenge is that argument
is it's an emotional argument that
perpetuates the crisis and creates more
suffering right and keeps people from
wanting to really deal with the more
common issue which is people pouring
across the border illegally it's like
when you when you concentrate on that
and and which really isn't happening i'm
very infrequently
you're missing the the boat on what we
really need to be doing which is
enforcing our immigration laws and
protecting the people of this country
more people we keep letting in we're
watering down what it means to be an
american we're watering down every thing
that we're paying into as american
citizens services are being watered down
and we don't have access to it we're
watering down
the job situation for middle class
families we're competing now for low
wage the low wage workers are coming in
and taking bringing our wages down it's
hurting the middle class
let me give you a scenario ian so uh
there are a lot of memes where people
say we could we could end starvation
around the world we have enough food to
feed all starving people why aren't we
doing it because tomorrow they're going
to be hungry again it's not about that
it's that we have the capacity to make
enough food to make it so they're never
hungry again teach a man to fish don't
you know why we don't just go to
starving nations and just give them food
because then they overpopulate they have
kids and then within a few years now you
have twice as many starving people and
you're like hey wait a minute we
increased suffering in the world
so you can't just give food to someone
you got to teach them to grow and
sustain their own economies and their
own food sources
that's the issue when you have someone
come here illegally
to to have a kid and try and give them
citizenship to exploit and break the law
it causes pain and suffering and damage
so it's kind of crazy this idea that
people have it's like a woman when she
was in her 20s was pregnant came to the
united states and had a kid the kid is
now seven years old so the police are
gonna come and arrest the mother and
send and send her back to mexico or to
guatemala or whatever and then they go
you can't do that she has a kid now that
would cause suffering and it's like yo
uh she broke the law
like the people who live here agree with
it's like
there's there's something about scale
that democrats don't seem to understand
where simply because they don't see it
happening they don't care what like
someone broke into your house
and then invited their friend in and
their friend would be homeless if you
kicked him out
yeah sorry dude get out well why is the
kid of an illegal immigrant an american
why 14th amendment but what is it 14th i
think is that redundant now like why
i don't understand just because the
kid's born on this side of the line it's
actually an exploitation of of the
constitution the original idea around
birthright citizenship was to uh it was
after the civil war
they the dred scott decision said that
uh descendants of africa could not be
citizens of this country after the civil
war we amended the constitution with the
14 i believe it was the 14th that said
this that if you're born here you're a
citizen this was basically to say all of
those people who are who are former
slaves you're citizens
but it became if you're born here you're
just a citizen like almost no country
does that almost none i think there's
like two or three or something like that
there's an argument to be made that um
that you know you're called the anchor
anchor babies that that is um wow that
you could find an offensive term well
that that's what they they call they
come in if you know border states deal
with this problem like for example yuma
arizona their maternity wards at 125
percent
americans aren't really having a lot of
babies these days but people come across
the border they even call it birth birth
tourism exactly they come here you're
seven months pregnant you stay a couple
months and you have the baby here and
now you have an american citizen that's
that's that's and then there's
the anchor bay because it anchors the
family here and there's something called
chain migration in china it's an
industry where they'll they will fly
pregnant women because you get dual
citizenship now your kids a citizen of
the united states you bring them back to
china when they're old enough when you
have a kid here what they do is now
they're a citizen they then can file
sponsorship to bring other people the
entire family no it's an exploit it's
gotta be dealt with i'm very
compassionate towards humans in general
and
but that's insanity that you can just
let someone
the kid the kids already we're talking
about roe v wade and it's a human it's
already a person according to a lot of
these people anyway so like what's the
difference of when it exits the birth
canal
i'm trying to find the law i think was
an 1885 law that talks about that
um
but i can't think of it off the top of
my head i'm going to look it up
you know these are these are questions
we have to ask as a country and we are
compassionate people americans are but
when are we going to start using our
brains we can't have open borders with
people pouring across yes or we won't
have a country our citizenship will mean
nothing it will be it'll mean nothing to
be an american if we just let people
pour in and we don't know who's coming
in and
when president trump said we're not
sending they're not sending their their
best and brightest he he's right the
stats show thousands of people coming in
who are murder suspects
dui suspects rape suspects so some
really bad people are coming in
terrorists are coming in
and and i'm not saying everybody who's
coming in is a really bad person but
we're allowing really bad people the
cartels to control our immigration can
you imagine
these narco terrorists are in control of
our immigration right now
we aren't yeah i'm not comfortable with
that i'm not comfortable with the people
coming in living in a border state our
streets are not safe i used to feel safe
walking across a parking lot in the
middle of the day or at night and i
don't feel safe anymore
yeah let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show and become a
member at timcast.com because we're
going to have that members only show
coming up at about 11 p.m tonight you
don't want to miss it it's the after
hours uncensored show but let's read
some of these super chats
nick koenig says hey tim when will you
have alex jones on again all of his
episodes are awesome um i don't know
maybe soon you know what we want to do
is we want to do friday night live irl
at venue at a venue
where we would sell like a couple
hundred tickets so there's a live
audience watching the show it would be
interesting because then we'd have to do
stage blocking where it's like everyone
would sit on one side of the table you
know you know that's right oh yeah yeah
yeah but i would love to have alex uh
come down for that so you know we'll
reach out and uh how cool would it be if
we did a friday night event it was an
extended show like a three hour show and
then we had alex and maybe somebody else
and it's just live in front of everybody
and on youtube of course that'd be a
whole lot of fun
but uh all right let's see we got
marshall p says i heard some promo with
carrie lake recently she is a warrior
love her
thank you marshall well there you go
appreciate it
all right there's a warrior inside all
of us right
yeah you see that meme of the the guy
with two wolves one is
hate and one is love and you have to
control them both i don't know what it
is well we did this poster behind me i
don't know colton can you grab one of
them i want to show it because somebody
said it looks like a superhero i just
happen to have it in arizona we have the
coolest flag in arizona
and and i guess this is me with my
warrior spirit but i just happened to
have that on and we're we were trying to
show off the um here it is
so
i guess what i'm showing here is that
there is a warrior in all of us and
we just have to find that kind of
fighting spirit i think we've got the
dna of our founding fathers i did not
realize they were 18 and 19 year olds
but they're
they were warriors and we've got that in
us and i think we're at a time right now
where we all need to tap into that
energy and say we're going to protect
this country save this country and do
the right thing and sometimes it's
uncomfortable we have to have these
conversations where you go but you're
not being compassionate no actually we
are being compassionate because um when
we we don't follow the laws that are
that are put forth we're hurting other
people we're hurting arizonans we're
hurting americans all right we got this
from
ken uh
kenk he says carrie
as an australian i want to commend you
on how you handled yourself during your
interview with liam bartlett the most
embarrassing thing is he's not even our
worst journalist not even close ooh
really there's worse out there i thought
liam was the absolute worst that we ever
faced
colton is he the worst we ever faced
i agreed to do it i thought okay 60
minutes wants to talk to us australia
about
you know the the rise of kind of the
trump republican the america first
movement what's coming after trump so we
agreed to do it we sat down and he's
interviewing us from australia via
laptop this guy had a raging case stage
four trump derangement syndrome every
question was just attacking me i'm
thinking i'm looking around going did
president trump you know sneak into the
room it's just me in here
um absolute lunatic doesn't even realize
what's going on in the world we talked
about our gun rights and our second
amendment and we talked about how they
have no freedom because they melted down
their guns in australia
it's a great interview go to my rumble
page and take a look at it it might be
the most deranged reporter i've ever
dealt with and i've dealt with some of
them all right cigars and sig arms says
kerry if elected governor what is your
plan on addressing the disturbing trend
of police brutality in cities like mesa
tempe and prescott
well i think we
frankly need to take some of the
pressure off of our police and right now
our police force is so under not only
underfunded because the craziest idea in
the world was defund the police but but
police and good police are walking away
because they don't the pressure
they're understaffed they're overworked
um they're being ripped apart in the
media and and called the bad guys and
there's a lot of pressure on them and i
think when you have that kind of
pressure on officers sometimes you're
going to have situations like you're
talking about
they're not all perfect just like all
human beings i think though that the
majority of police are really good and
want to do the right thing
i think when we started seeing all these
cops resign and i think we just saw a
news story about a ton of cops resigning
in new york you're not left with no
police like some people would hope
you're left with the bad ones and then
on top of it during covet i know we
can't talk about the
shot in the arm but they were taking our
first responders we're already
understaffed i mean some some police
departments aren't half staffing
in arizona we're i think or three or
four hundred cops down
and then they all of a sudden say you
know what if you don't get the
shot in the arm you're out
so they were mandating they were
mandating that and so
who's the kind of person that's gonna
say no to that i think strong
constitutionally minded people are going
to say hell no
and those are the police you want
frankly the people who follow the
constitution who believe in individual
rights we want those people on our
police force and those were the kind of
police they were pushing away in arizona
were they making them take the jab yeah
could if you became governor can you
undo that we're gonna work on that we
are absolutely one of my top priorities
is that this is outrageous to have any
boss an employer tell you medically what
you have to do some medical and you know
you talked about back vasectomies can
you imagine if your employer said you
can work here but i need proof that
you've had a vasectomy that's crazy stop
this this is craziness we we have one
this one is um
i'll just read it wolf on the plane says
tim it's future madam president carrie
lake address her properly she should be
our first female potus she's got my vote
is he in arizona i don't know but um
cause the ballots are out and what we
need to do is we've got the young people
voting we need to get the young people
to fill out those ballots and send them
in um
that's really nice let me let me first
take on the job in arizona i don't have
political aspirations i think i'm
probably the only person in politics who
really
i i look at politics and it's slimy it's
gross i just want to get in and get
arizona on the right track i don't have
any aspirations beyond that but i take
that as a huge compliment thank you
yeah you you answered before i could ask
but i assume your answer would be i'm
going to focus on my gubernatorial
campaign because people are asking ron
desantis as well and he's like look i'm
running for governor in florida
talk about presidential aspirations
after later on i'll let ron go that
direction i just want to get arizona on
track i hate washington d.c no offense
at least i really hate it right now with
joe biden there um i love arizona and i
want to do right by the people of
arizona so that's my concentration right
now
so it'll be 2028 desantis lake ticket
huh
i do love ron desantis that guy is vent
fantastic and he gets it i don't know
that he had media training i mean he
wasn't in the media before but i believe
his wife is it casey was in the media so
maybe she's kind of worked with him
because he knows exactly how to deal
with these people in the media half of
them are losers maybe more he's fearless
yeah
all right yeah his wife casey won an
emmy that's right oh wow and i want to
say that i think president trump knows
how to deal with the media as well he's
a little more brash and maybe not as
polished
um some people say that i'm like trump
in address
which might help me get some democrat
votes actually
um
but
you know president trump was one of the
first politicians to go after the media
and call them out and thank god he did
because he opened people's eyes you are
fake news remember that yeah you are
fake news
i dig it all right let's see kyle ella
says tim please read this i'm in front
of one i'm from one of the three poorest
counties in ohio the only thing we have
is natural gas biden is doing everything
he can to keep the gas in the ground and
keep rural folks poor and dependent on
the government
what county i want to know
rural america
is being put on the back burner actually
they're not even on the stove
and it's happening in arizona we've got
a county maricopa county where maine
population is six six and a half seven
million people live there the rest of
people live throughout the state
and
they don't get the attention they need
they pay into the taxes but the voting
base maricopa county is so massive 65 70
of the vote comes from maricopa county
so a lot of politicians they just
concentrate on the city centers
and they just say screw the rest of them
and we are going to be the first
governor who says no we are putting
rural arizona small town arizona on the
front burner they've been ignored for
far too long like i said i mentioned
that that bridge over that um that wash
that was flooding every time it rained
and they couldn't can you imagine you
have to drive a 40 minute a 40 minute
detour
to get you know a quarter of a mile
people were just driving through the
flooded road and it was killing people
but they they get ignored they get
ignored and we need to start putting the
hard-working people tax-paying people
backbone of our country
on the front burner and giving them some
attention
all right let's read this we got geno
brown says hey carrie shared this with
my family hoping they see how awesome
you are policy question as governor do
you have a plan to convince the state
democrats to work with republicans in
the interest of saving arizonans from
these upcoming hardships
just all hardships in general i'd love
to work with the democrats i mean i i
like to call myself an america first
candidate i'm a conservative running as
a republican i believe the republican
party is based on conservative values
and that's what our country was based on
but the left is always kind of evil
genius when they when it comes to words
and they've tried to castigate what it
means to be a conservative
being a conservative means that you want
uh you want policies that help americans
help you prosper
but keep the government out of get the
government out of your way we're not
supposed to be your babysitter and
handing out giving handouts we're
supposed to create an environment where
you can live the american dream and
we've had progressives on this show who
said the goal of government is to
provide the services to the people
and and i'm just like we're all like no
the goal of government really should be
to protect our border to be honest make
sure we have roads that are our travel
that we can travel on and are
are safe it's like common defense yeah
real basic and get back
so um
i think we can work together i think
people are waking up i think people are
fleeing the democrat party right now in
droves in droves and i'm excited about
it they're waking up as they wake up i
want them to come right over to the
republican party it's the party of
common sense the party of ideas that
work and the party of safety and
security and so i hope they'll come over
and that'll help us deal with some of
these problems we're going to have i
believe a super majority and get a lot
of things done well all right we got a
good one here from
wathak he says he joined a little late
but forgive me if it's already been
brought up he wanted to ask what are
your views and plans on arizona water
and sustainability i'm especially
concerned with the colorado river
compact
we have a water issue in arizona i mean
we actually do have a lot of water
underground but we can't conserve our
way out of a drought and we can't
regulate our way out of a drought and i
can't solve the water problem here on on
the tim cast tonight it's a very complex
water situation we've been trying to
deal with it for years
but one thing i do know is arizona is
growing as these blue states lose their
minds and go crazy people are running to
our great red states and we're going to
have that growth and we so we need to
look at bringing more water in
because arizona is going to keep growing
and we don't want to have water become
an issue where we can't sustain that
growth i want to look at piping water in
from the mississippi and missouri river
basin we've got the right of way we can
we pipe oil from all over the country
and well we used to before joe biden and
from alaska we can build pipes and pipe
water easily we could mitigate flooding
in the midwest and other parts of the
country and and bring water to arizona
one thing that uh is not a permanent
solution but if you look at las vegas
they've actually started terraforming
and reclaiming the desert
by tourism
so what people don't realize is
when that plane flies into vegas it's
carrying several hundred people who are
full of water those people get off the
plane sweat use the bathroom and that
water enters the local area and they
leave it there it then evaporates and
you start seeing uh
they're also i mean aside from that
they're planting grass
but uh there's
there's a massive terraform i don't know
if that's gonna totally solve our
problem well no what i'm saying is um
one thing to consider is
las vegas is actually
uh d what's the what's the word
desalination no desertification
it's a desert there's no water but all
of the food being shipped in all the
people that come and go are bringing
water and leaving it there and the water
remains and then you see clouds starting
to form so now las vegas is actually
starting to get moisture back we need to
look at every idea and one of them is
desalination and right now we're looking
at maybe having a desalination plant
with our neighbors in mexico sadly we
can't work with california because the
regulations and their politics are so
kooky that we can't work with them but
we'd like to
they should have desal plants up and
down that coastline they have one in the
san diego area it's working great
and you can do private public
partnerships to you know get the the
capital down to get these built
we'll work with mexico if we have to we
desalinate water from the sea of portez
we could either give mexico that water
and then trade their colorado river
allotment or we could also pump in water
from the sea of cortez that's been
desalinated we have a lot of water
underground in arizona that's brackish
and we could desalinate that we need to
look at every single option brackish
water underground yeah it's open
i don't know how it's brackish but we we
can clean it up and use it
i think we need to look at everything
even the big pie in the sky ideas you
know it was like 40 years ago the
central arizona project our aquifer
system was developed and everyone
thought it's impossible oh we can't it's
just it's too out there
and
we used to think big
back then we had men in power and men
who were leaders and women as well but
mainly men back then who thought big
they thought let's build the palo verde
nuclear power plant let's prepare for
the future of arizona now we're in this
area of big thinking is how can we get
the taxpayers to pay for a sports arena
you can use the salt from the
desalination for molten salt reactors so
that overnight the salt stays hot and
liquid and then continues to boil water
for steam power overnight you can also
build these solar powered water
condensers which where the the air goes
in through a tube down underground uh to
and then cools down with these uh
cooling mechanisms that are powered by a
solar generator and yeah then condenses
into water and then they're just local
like you just have one on every street
corner kind of you got the water in the
air
so there's a survival stuff they sell
where it's like a big a bunch of [ __ ]
it's like a cube and it takes even in
dry very arid conditions it can zap that
water especially underground
the water condenses from the air onto it
and then it falls down into a container
or some kind of we just have to look at
at every option and we need to get our
federal delegation together and we're
going to have democrats in there and
republicans and i think this is an issue
where we can come together because
democrats drink water and so do
republicans but we need to send our
delegation our congressmen and our
senators back to dc and say
we
want some help on the water issue and
we're not going to sign off on a bunch
of your projects until you help us it's
not going to cost a lot of money
nothing costs a lot of money when you
compare what they're sending to ukraine
we could have solved this problem with
some of that money we sent to ukraine
fix this problem but they drag their
feet they drag their feet they throw all
of these epa studies in and try to slow
this and we're talking about water we
need we can't go a day without water
so i think if we put our heads together
and we and we have the will to do right
we can make this happen and i want to be
the governor that spearheads that right
on so we have opie who said just got my
ballot and voted kerry lake let's fix a
z
so people are already voting well i'm
smiling over here i don't mean to keep
checking my phone but i'm the ballots
just went out and obviously they're
arriving at people's homes and i'm
getting pictures
left and right like this one right here
someone just said make us proud he just
cast a vote for me
right on so i'm really excited about
that and i will make them proud i am you
know i've got people coming up to me on
the campaign trail
these are men who fought wars
saw combat
women who've lived
to be 70 80 years old and have had a
really full life
moms dads you name it they come up to me
and they grab me with tears in their
eyes and they're like please save
arizona i'm so worried about where we're
going please save it i would rather die
than disappoint the people of arizona
i am not doing this for any other reason
that i love arizona i love the people
i've covered this state for 27 years and
i've watched as over and over again we
get political figures who come in
promise one thing do the opposite and
they they
leave the people behind and they don't
care about the people of arizona and i'm
tired of seeing that and it's going to
stop when i'm governor all right we got
one uh this is this is a little edgier
joe smith says why are women like carrie
lake marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
the only political leaders with balls
and please forgive me who is the
absurdly cute young blonde woman oh okay
that's mary i guess
she is cute thank you
but uh it is interesting right that um i
actually get asked that a lot they're
like why don't we have any men
um
we do have men with balls
a lot of them
desantis they're great i'm a mama bear
to a baby i got two baby cubs i told you
i got a girl and a boy i'm really
concerned about our boys right now
i like to you know i came from a family
of eight girls and one boy that's where
i grew up i was the youngest so i i've
always believed that i can do anything i
never thought that being a woman meant i
couldn't do something
i'm worried about the environment our
boys have been living in they've been
pushed down told to check their toxic
masculinity the metoo movement they're
probably even afraid to try to ask a
girl out because it's just gotten so so
toxic
i want to see us help strengthen our men
right now
and i think maybe men are reluctant to
jump into politics maybe because of that
i i i don't look at people and go we
need to be in the female box the mailbox
we need to just all come together as
americans and do right right now i think
we've got great strong men in there
maybe
it's odd or strange to see women who are
just speaking the truth
and
we're kind of
making some news out there i guess yeah
all right
shino tenchi says thought you'd all like
to know i'm getting kicked out of the
navy for hate speech due to a false
allegation because of supporting trump
their evidence was memes from 2017-18 on
my phone and a book from the babylon bee
oh wow that's crazy military's gone woke
what does trump say everything woke
i don't want to say it okay
turns to poop yeah there you go
like don't make me swear yeah well go
bro you really don't want the military
going woke that's the last thing you
want going woke or the schools or really
anything
i heard that the military the u.s
military is the greatest polluting
organism on earth if it was a
corporation it pollutes more than any
any other corporation which i'm fine
with because it's the military i mean i
don't like pollution yeah but like you
know got to do the job first clean the
pollution up afterwards protect the
people right
i hope he's um is he getting kicked out
or did he get kicked out
he said he was getting kicked
out yeah that's tragic actually dude
all right
robbie pratt says tim when will you put
a bug zapper in the chicken coop to
provide free food for the chickens buck
buck buck
that's a good idea
are people talking about eating bugs i
just saw a celebrity this week saying
something about eating bugs oh you don't
eat bugs we all eat bugs here everybody
yeah yeah we got some you want a bowl of
crickets while we do the show no
ian and i uh made a cricket bread once
to try it out it was lackluster yeah i
didn't it wasn't special it was just
cricket
and i think about the pol pot regime in
cambodia when
when they just destroyed that country
and they had a huge um really a
holocaust really i mean they killed was
it two or three million people
in in cambodia pol pot and they when
they marched people out of the cities
and and that's when they started
foraging for food and they eat bugs and
when i was in cambodia they still to
this day forage for bugs and eat bugs
all right
uh we have this one from box fed tv
there's a lot here so i don't know if we
can get to all of it because a lot of
questions they say love you carry one
ban atf in arizona ban fbi in arizona
repeal patriot act we'll start there
wow okay i'm writing notes what does he
want me to do well so i'll ask you this
i think it was new hampshire and
missouri have uh basically said they
will not assist the federal government
in enforcing gun laws
would you same being you'd be in favor
of the same thing in arizona anything
unconstitutional taking away from our
second amendment rights we are a second
amendment sanctuary state and we're not
going to take these gun laws that
they're passing
and enforce them so you're already a
sanctuary state for gun laws yeah we're
all right on i think that answers but i
think it's interesting that this last
couple of weeks i think it was maybe a
week and a half ago two weeks by now
that they passed that uh the supreme
court um ruled against the epa and some
of these
far overreaching
agencies
where they're not elected officials
they're not elected by the people trying
to control every aspect of our life and
they found that
they ruled against that so i think
there's a lot of pushback we can do on
some of these agencies and i think we've
now got precedent that's been set by the
supreme court
all right let's read some more
trying to screen some uh super chats in
the meantime
all right let's see what we got
charles fritz says russia has been
trying to get ukraine to keep their food
exports going the entire war and ukraine
refuses to
hm
well all right
sparky says carrie why didn't president
trump pardon assange
do you know i don't know
i was like i don't ask him that i do
talk to him regularly i've talked to him
a couple times this week and last week
haven't asked that i think i have an
answer
why donald trump wanted julian assange
extradited because
i believe that trump thinks assange has
evidence that will help trump against
the bureaucratic state against those who
are lying about him
against bad people
so
i think the obama administration was
content to effectively assassinate
julian assange by locking him away and
making it difficult for him to do any
work
donald trump was like this guy knows
something because julian assange was
assange was talking about seth rich so
trump was like get him here
apparently there was some there was like
a rumors about a deal where it was like
you'll like give us information let us
know the truth and we'll let you go or
something i think that's what trump was
trying to do
so that's why he didn't pardon him but
maybe we'll see what happens with the
with this i think a second trump term is
going to be
like i don't know rainbows and rainbows
and lollipops i i think trump's going to
go in there and he's going to do
everything people really wanted i say
he's coming back and he's coming back
with a vengeance yeah he announced his
plane he showed it that isn't it yeah
those things run like 20 million bucks
20 million bucks for a 757 then you got
to staff it you got to feel loved the
way he had the flag on the back it
wasn't just it was like a furling flag
unfurled flag i think what you say i got
to watch that thing pull up at his
rallies a couple times i think like
three or four times because i was
covering his rallies in 2015 and 16. so
you'd be in the hangar and you'd see it
just slowly inching up after it landed
and then everyone's screaming and then
you know they make their way in
it was a sight to be hold that's for
sure
all right let's see we got
christopher macy says tim i'm the owner
of rebuilding life gardens llc i started
my own food forest and support kerry
lake and could help with food production
and food
oh very cool that's awesome is he in
arizona i wonder i'm assuming that means
he's in arizona maybe there's so many
creative people and amazing people in
arizona i mean we're the patriots that
kind of got this whole thing looking
into the election going
arizonans just to be in arizona
obviously we have 22 native tribes there
but people who came to arizona the
pioneers who got into the
covered wagons and came across there's a
certain spirit to do that and that means
your ancestors had that spirit even if
you came across the country to arizona
in you know 1970 or 1990 in a car
there's a certain kind of spirit of
somebody who says i'm going to relocate
to a new state
and and we're us really special people
oh yeah sounds like he's one rebuilding
lifegardens.com is phoenix arizona llc
look into that rebuilding
lifegardens.com
all right
recro morrison says the huge danger is
also people like carrie lake desantis
christie and others showing canadians
alberta saskatchewan northern ottawa the
good in american values liberals are
scared maga
that's the thing too i think trudeau
mentioned it that because the american
press the culture is sort of seeping
into uh into canada you see it with like
the trucker protest loved that when you
talked about the farmer protest i was
thinking of canada with those truckers
they freaked out over that they do not
like it all right
christian says i'm in favor of children
having jobs i worked on a ranch starting
at 12 best thing that has ever happened
to me
i think so too i think kids should have
some kind of work i'm not saying they
should be working it teaches a work
ethic right i'm seeing that lacking a
lot right now i don't know i mean i'm
not of your generation but do you see
that as well i told my kids they're both
working right now if you just go to work
show up early work hard
you are going to go so far in this world
because we're kind of lacking i think
that work ethic that maybe we used to
have you don't go so far you know what's
really funny
is there are young people who won't work
40 hours a week to save up so they can
buy the new car
or a new skateboard or whatever but
there are people who will play video
games for 40 hours to earn the helm of
disintegration or something oh man
they're like i got the new upgraded
helmet it only took me 30 hours to get
it's like dude get a job save up money
and buy a car man yeah what about the
real world is less appealing well i
think it's scary i think it's scary i
think a lot of young people have been
protected they've been you know the kind
of helicopter mom and dad protecting
them from the real world
and school's not preparing them for the
real world and so they get out of school
they're 18 and they're like oh my gosh
they know they're not ready they know
they're not prepared they know they
don't have the skills nothing is scarier
than walking into a job on day one or
i'm three weeks in and thinking you're
not
prepared for that
and that's why we've got to give them
the skills that creates the confidence
for them to do anything and then build
on that
to have success
jay button says can we get a tim cast
dnd show like critical role we tried
doing a dnd show we didn't have the
wherewithal to put together but
we are going to get all of that rolling
it's tough look uh we're doing we're
doing well
we have a good amount of members and
we're stretched about as thin as we can
be stretched for the time being until we
really start bringing it here's where
it's here's where we're at we have a lot
of members
now we need to make some shows so we've
got tales from the inverted world the
episodes are going to be like 45 minutes
to an hour long it's crazy this
investigation to the lost confederate
gold and everything that came uh next to
it
that show needs to generate more members
because you know tim cast has has gotten
as many members it basically can get
it's at that upper limit now we do
another show hopefully that will
generate a certain amount of members who
will be willing to pay for this new
content and then you have exponential
growth from there so we want to do
everything i'd love to have 300 shows
produce all of this stuff that's just
not woke just regular good old-fashioned
content that you could enjoy and have a
good time but there will be values in it
it'll just be like individualism liberty
you know things like that so we just
have to build to it so uh as you guys go
to teamcast.com and become members you
are helping us
expand to that degree but hopefully
we'll end up with a show that's like
game of thrones-esque or whatever and
then we end up with a million
subscribers and then we can do
everything so
i'll i'll leave it there if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel and head over to
timcast.com become a member because
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up as soon as we wrap the live
stream we start recording that this
one's going to be uncensored
after hours you can also follow the show
at tim cast irl you can follow me at tim
cast carrie do you want to shout
anything out
yeah if you're an arizona vote i mean i
think the young people i think the young
people are really involved right now in
politics they realize how politics have
affected their lives the last few years
they realize people mask them they
realize that people tortured them and
took some of the great moments of their
life away and they're very involved now
in politics i want them to vote if
they've got a ballot in their mailbox
get it out and vote this is between a
rhino who's an open borders globalist
married to a 95 year old pouring
billions of dollars into ads trying to
say she's one thing when she's another
thing she's at open borders really
liberal and it's between a socialist
democrat and myself so we got to pick
the right person and that's me i will
say this um
in a general sense
when you believe in someone and you want
to vote bring three of your friends with
you
convince three of your friends to come
and vote with you or if you've got a
mail-in ballot convince your friends to
vote as well i'm not telling you who to
vote for i'm just saying
do that outreach yourself because that's
the grassroots that ripple effect has an
impact
truly does and we are a grassroots uh
campaign and we're going to do big
things for arizona and i'm only in this
because i was looking at who ran and i
thought none of these people are going
to put arizonans first and and i think
it's the experienced uh political people
that got us into this mess and we need
outsiders to get us out i've been
covering arizona for 27 years my job was
to go in every day wrap my arms around
the biggest issue facing arizona and get
the information out to the people we
need a great communicator much like
ronald reagan was now because
information in those who control it are
really controlling the population and we
need somebody who can break down the
truth for people and actually get some
stuff done you know i think the mom and
me is going to get some stuff done in
that midwestern work ethic right on do
you have a website people can go to if
they want to support you directly
carrylake.com
k-a-r-i-l-a-k-e dot com you can see
where i stand on all of the issues and
i'm not talking about just a sentence i
lay it all out i've got my border policy
there my homelessness policy my
education policy
and much more and i also have uh where
my opponent the one who's trying to buy
this race she's out spending us 20 to
one she's it's the most expensive
governor's race we've ever seen and
we're not even to the primary yet
expected to spend 26 million dollars
most of it in ads that are
painting her as something that she
really isn't
so we need to let her know that we're
not going to allow her to buy this
election she can spend all the money she
wants but we're not going to buy her
lies and you can see what her voting
record is before you cast that ballot
right on
all right well we also have mary morgan
who's hanging out you want to shout
anything out sure if you want to see
more of me you can find me on instagram
or wechat at closer kitty and i also
demand that you go find pop culture
crisis on youtube we go live at 3 p.m
eastern and noon pacific time every
monday through friday this week is a
little different you can find a
pre-recorded episode tomorrow uh and
we're going to be talking about
celebrity news entertainment news
tv movies all that light-hearted stuff
that you won't see on tim cast irelle so
come join us
and you can follow me at ian
crossland.net get in touch with me via
social media anyone you want i'm usually
on all of them carrie always awesome to
see you man thank you and i will call
you dude and man all day
oh i'm totally looking forward to it
i'll tell you remind me again after the
show if i don't remind you first pink
shirts
we don't have pink but uh pull maybe you
can pull the shirts up and we'll show
we'll get every one of you guys a shirt
you're going to love it you'll and
you'll think about me when you lay down
for sleep because they're so comfortable
to bed tonight it's very comfortable
thank you again that's awesome yeah
thank you so much for coming carrie and
i want to say on the topic of pop
culture we talk a lot about politics
being downstream from culture so that's
a very strong pitch for figuring out
what's going on with culture a lot of
people dismiss what's going on there but
it's very much having a finger to the
pulse of what's happening in the real
world more than just politics thank you
again for coming carrie you guys can
follow me on twitter and mines.com
sarahpatulitz as well sourpatchlids.me
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com for the special members only
section of this show thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all there
you